This is Jocko podcast number
91 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink. Good
Evening Echo. Good evening.
And we are rolling straight
into Q and a today.
So questions from the interwebs.
Echo Charles Gulf
go. Okay, first question
Jocko. I've just finished about
faith, the book, amazing book,
interested how you modeled your style on
Hackworth though hack was a renegade in
always bending the rules to
break to the breaking point,
but in extreme ownership he talk about,
for example,
not pushing back on higher command
when it came to Iraqi troops.
Have listened to podcasts too,
but was hoping you could go
into it a bit more. Yeah,
so I guess that that's a good question.
Hack.
He was kind of considering a renegade,
but,
but also he's also a total company man
that you got to realize that there's that
dichotomy there. There's a
guy that hack, loved the army,
he loved the army, he wanted his
uniform would look super squared away.
He followed all the rules
and regulations that,
and he supported the leadership all the
time when the leadership was right and
that's what makes him a good renegade.
In my opinion and I was very much the
same way. I was all about the navy.
You know, I was all about the
games as a matter of fact tone.
You know what Tony used to say?
Uh,
it was a little thing we got going
in to you bruiser that spread around.
But of course it came from Tony First,
which was all navy all the time.
We'd just be joking
about, you know, I think,
I don't know what originally caused it,
but like guys would make fun of me because
I would wear like jungle boots or Dan
or boots out too on liberty with
a clear of like old jeans. Yeah.
Cause when you're, when you're like that
kind of old just raised in the teams,
you don't even know any
different and you're like,
oh well I'm going out and I need to wear
shoes. Cool. Where's my jungle boots?
That's what you end up like. And,
and you're into it. You're not like,
you think it's good. You think it's
normal. Like this is the way things are.
And so I supported the teams and
hack supported the army of course.
But this is the thing,
if the leadership was wrong or there
was something being passed down that was
wrong and it was a big wrong,
like if it was a little,
I wouldn't be like, Oh man, this is crap.
They're making us wear a
different pair of shorts now.
Because like that would happen.
Like some new commanding officer would
come in and change some thing, right.
And some, well we got to do that. We're,
it's like, dude, be quiet. You know,
just be quiet. Do you know they're giving
you a new shorts where the new shorts,
you know, oh, they're telling us we
can't wear baseball hats anymore. Cool.
Don't wear baseball hats. And
some grass would go, who cares?
I don't care what I'm wearing
on my head. You know, like,
oh you want to issue with different
ball caps are fine, whatever.
But then if it was a larger issue then or,
or obviously if it was something
that was like actually wrong,
like criminally wrong or morally wrong
or something like that, then yeah,
I'd be like, no, we can't do that.
So the reason that I didn't push back
on Iraqi troops in working with Iraqi
troops when we got to Ramadi
was because as I looked at it,
I realized that it was the
right thing to do and yes,
it was going to be more dangerous.
And yes,
a definitely took us
out of our comfort zone.
But as I explain in extreme ownership,
if we didn't train those people up,
if we didn't train the Iraqi soldiers
and take them out and get them fighting
and get them squared
away on the battlefield,
then Americans would have
been doing it forever.
So it was the correct call was to do that.
Now I've,
I've talked about the same, same
thing. When they told us our ratio,
they gave us a ratio of how many Iraqis
we had to have for every one Iraqi we
had to have, I don't know what their,
I forget what the number was, seven or,
or for every one seal we had
to have seven Iraqi soldiers.
They said that something like that.
I forget what the numbers were.
And I said,
no,
that doesn't make sense to us because
sometimes we only have 10 guys to go out
and I'm,
there's no way I'm sending only one seal
with 10 Iraqi soldiers not doing it.
Need a corpsman, need to
radio man, need a machine,
gunner need a leader like
that. That's what I need. So,
and when I pushed back because I didn't
push back against ball caps and because
I didn't push back against
some stupid uniform change, ah,
they were like, oh yeah, well that
actually makes sense. Chocolate.
We don't want you to go on
the field with only one seal.
So I would clearly pushed back if it
was something that didn't make sense.
Same thing with like the martial arts
training that they had us doing in the,
in the late nineties and early
two thousands. It was not good.
And I was told everyone, hey, this
is not smart. This is not good.
This training is dumb. We need to
do other training that's better. Uh,
and, and same thing,
you know, things go, oh,
like here's another like stupid example.
They wouldn't want to issue
a platoon that the radio was,
you are going to take on deployment
because they didn't want you to break them
or whatever. And so they'd issue
not enough radios for everyone.
And so now not everyone does know how to
operate the radios and you're basically
operationally testing the radios while
you're going through your workup.
So I said, hey, this is garbage issue,
everyone radios if that's how we operate,
that's how we need to train.
Gotcha.
So in the training they would
an issue that the radios, yeah,
there was a time period where we low on
radios and they said we're going to keep
these radios for deployment and it's,
that doesn't make sense.
I got a good idea by more
radios. Uh, so, you know,
those were things I pushed back on it
and you were always pushing back on the
type of training that was going
to happen and who is going to be,
how you're going to run
the training. So, um,
when something we didn't
made sense to push back,
I pushed back just like Hackworth did.
Now,
Hackworth did it on a massive
scale because he eventually
pushed back on the way
the war in Vietnam was being run.
And had I been smart enough and the war
didn't take the shift that it took and
we didn't move towards counterinsurgency
and we didn't make those adjustments
that the, that carnal McFarland
implemented in Ramadi. Maybe,
maybe, I doubt it. Maybe I would
have been smarter to say, Hey,
we're not running this war right.
We need to do something different and
run it up the chain of command. But,
but at the time, you know, Colonel
Mcfarlane made great decisions. He led,
he had a great plan, a great
strategy, so I was 100% on board. Um,
but if you don't Hackworth,
that didn't happen.
They were not fighting correctly
against the Vietnamese and,
and they were taking massive casualties
for a hill that two days later they'd
give back. And so he was saying, what
are you doing? And, and the other thing,
you know,
when he took over the hardcore battalion,
they were fighting for
months and they had,
they had literally killed almost,
no, anyway, I think it was zero.
I think there's actually zero enemy.
And yet they had taken all kinds of
casualties themselves. And so he'd say,
w w this is wrong, this is
wrong. So I think that's,
that's what being a leader is. You support
the stuff, you support the command.
Yes, of course we support the command when
it makes sense and as long as it makes
sense and normally it's gonna make sense.
You know what I mean?
Normally it's going to make sense.
It's not like the,
the admirals and the generals are
saying, hey, how can we lose this war?
Let's come up with a stupid strategy.
No, they're doing the best they can.
So it's not like it's a regular
occurrence. I mean, like I said,
when I was working for Carter,
Colonel Mcfarland, he was a smart guy.
He was a brilliant guy that had a great
strategy of, I'm like, okay, awesome.
I'm here to support. Um, and, and
I'll tell you when I did, and this is,
I think this is important,
is that even though I was kind of a
renegade and I was more rebellious when I
was a kid, obviously I, I was, uh, I was
young when I got the seal teams then. So,
you know, we would push all of
those things where I said that, oh,
we got to do this. That was me when I was
at e four in the seal teams. You know,
what do we go do that we should just be
able to do whatever we want. You know,
we were just stupid.
But as I got older,
I realized that you need to
come across as a renegade quote,
unquote, to come across as a
big rebel. That doesn't, well,
immediately when you go and push back on
something, everyone just dismisses you.
Oh yeah. Jocko, he's just
a loud mouth. He just,
he just pushed it back against
everything he doesn't want.
He's wanting to do everything his
way. No. You want them to say, Oh wow,
hold on a second. If jockos pushing
back against this, then this,
this must be something wrong here because
he doesn't push back against stuff.
He tells the line all the time
so we should listen to them.
That's what you want to build.
That's what I did my best to build and
that's how I think it would be comparable
to the way Hackworth led
and the way that I tried to,
obviously I know Hackworth,
but I stole as much as I could
from him and the weird thing is,
I'll tell you this,
I always say I stole from him,
but it wasn't like I was sitting
there reading a book and going,
I'm going to do what he did here.
I think it was just absorbed and even
even the naming of tasking at bruiser,
like when I did it, I wasn't
thinking this is what Hackworth did,
but it was real obvious that
that's where I got it from. Like,
I didn't think I'm going
to rename this and again,
we're going to turn this thing around
based order would not turn it around,
but we're going to build this based
on, no, I was like, you know what?
We're not going to be Task Unit Bravo
cause that sounds lame or maybe task you
had a bruiser because that sounds
awesome. You and, and, and then later,
you know, I was like fuck. I'm
like, Oh God, that's right.
That's exactly what Hackworth did.
I obviously stole it from him,
so appreciate it. Act. But that's
what I'd say be a renegade.
But that's should be,
that should be in the background.
That should be in the back of your mind,
in the front of your mind. Should be, hey,
I'm a supporter of what's happening.
Kind of like the willingness to be a
real renegade if you have to. Yeah, yeah.
If you have to end,
believe me,
I've known all kinds of good seals
that were to renegade. Yeah, yeah.
That's just like I'm a Renick.
Yeah, they're just straight
up, hey, I'm a renegade.
And, and you know that just the only
guys that could get away with that,
well guys that were so ultimately
operationally squared away. Yeah.
That people go, yeah, you know, he's
kind of a maniac, but dude, he's really,
really good and really tactically
sound and all that. And they could,
they make that happen.
Now as you get more and more senior
homie don't play like that after
a certain point, it's done.
And you've got to get, you've got to
play the game. That's what you got to do.
As you get more senior,
got to play the game.
And from like your subordinates viewpoint,
if, if they looked at me and go,
oh, jock was just playing the
game. He's just doing it to
be guests. I am. Yes I am.
Because this way it gives me more ability
to control everything that's going to
impact you. People that
work for me. So yes,
I'm going to play the game so you
don't have to. You're welcome.
So yeah, check your math. Makes Sense.
Next question.
Jujitsu.
Bjj Do.
You did too during your time in Iraq,
if you like,
please paint me a picture.
How to imagine a Bjj class
from you as an active soldier.
Did you have a g maths and how would
it differ from a quote unquote normal
class? Um, so yeah,
I always brought mass with me starting
with 1998 I think is when I started
bringing maths with me. How do you
bring meth? She just be like, Hey,
in military transport you build
something called a pallet.
So you get a big palette and there
there's like eight feet by eight feet are
pretty big and you put stack all
kinds of stuff on them and you know,
you've got your weapons, you got
your engines, you got your motors,
you got your motors, you got your
boats, your, your Zodiac boats,
you've got paddled,
you've got all this.
I mean all of the equipment [inaudible]
everyone's personal gear is on their,
their op gear, their body armor.
It's all of these big pallets.
And when you go on deployment,
you'll have eight pallets,
eight of these giant pallets.
And so on some of those pallets there
would be mats. So who is it up to though?
You know,
you're talking about weapons
and Zodiacs and stuff and like,
well whoever's in charge, which we're
seeing a lot of times this week.
So then it made it real easy and, and
even if it wasn't me, I mean everybody,
you know, if people are bringing something
to help everyone get better, you know,
I, yeah, that's cool. So in
that approval process, no man,
this guy's bringing all kinds of crazy
things. This man, I remember guys, well,
you know,
you guys should bring surfboards.
I mean they'd pack their
surfboards on pallets,
they pack a weights and squat
racks and anything that you want.
If you're going on a six month
deployment to remote location, yeah,
you're going to put your load, have a
squat rack and a bunch of bumper plates.
And if that remote location has waves,
you're packing surfboards. If it has,
if it has, you know, rock climbing,
you're going to pack rock climbing gear.
I'm telling you,
this is one of the things that
it's really hard to the seal teams.
It's really hard to have that.
I think we, I think in the,
the seal teams to have that better
than most people. It was just this,
this autonomy to kind of make things
happen and do kind of cool stuff.
And I'm not saying no, no one ever
gets to do that. But you know,
I don't think a regular
army unit or regular Marine
Corps unit would be putting,
you know, seven surfboards on their peers.
The where. So where's the limit though?
Like, so what can I, let's say
we're going, can we get a TV?
Can I get a tpa and PBM TVS? Like
the big screen. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It just,
it also depends on where you're deploying
and what you're doing and what the
mission is. Because you
know, my first time to Iraq,
we didn't have much of any of
this stuff obviously. Right?
We just had our op gear basically.
And, but the second time,
the second time I went to Iraq,
we brought more,
but we actually had to weld a squat
rack is pretty awesome. There's a,
there's a marine that, there was a great
marine that was with us and he ran,
he manned the radios and he was just a,
just an awesome guy.
And he was, he was a marine, but he was,
there was marines across the river.
And so he was supposed to keep continuity
and he got assigned to US anyways.
Awesome guy.
And he knew how to weld.
He was from a farm up
in Montana or something,
so he knew how to weld and he had the
gear and we didn't have a squat rack.
And so our CBS, cause there's a
bunch of cvs with us. They get,
they were able to like just come up
with stuff. They make anything happen.
My,
my head CB was just could see that's
CBS build things I think also acquire
things. Let's see. Comment builder.
It's a combat engineer battalion.
It's a construction battalion. That's
what it is. So it's CB for short,
but it's the CBS and so yeah,
they build things and they also are
very good at acquiring things. You know,
things just show up at your,
at your base.
And my guys were awesome at acquiring
things and we didn't have a squat rack,
which is, which is crazy to me to
be having no squat rack. Right. Why,
why don't you have a squat rack? So
this, this marine welded a squat rack.
Now here's the interesting part,
the squat rack, he was, he was tall,
he was like maybe six, four,
six, five, maybe not that
tall, but he was a mean guy,
the marine welder. So on the
squat rack there was, you know,
there's adjustable to put the bar on.
Well this didn't have adjustable things.
It just had two hooks and there was one
hook at his height or one set of hooks
at his height and one set
of hooks at my height.
Everyone just had to figure
it out from there, you know?
But uh, but yeah, so yeah,
you could bring, you could
bring that if you want it to.
And so, so yes, we brought maths,
I brought maths on that
deployment and both actually,
both of my deployment to Iraq brought
mats. And then one of the classic,
well generally you're training with
people that don't know anything.
And I would have trained with
them under the workup, you know,
so they're starting to learn
and they're like, you know,
low level white belts or mid level white
belts or even high level wipe butts.
I don't think we, I even had one blue
belt on either one of my deployments.
And the good thing is their team guys,
they're athletic, they're strong,
they're in good shape, they want to
learn. So they learn fast, they're tough.
They're like I said, strong and athletics.
So you're going to get good roles.
The more you teach them,
the better the roles get.
Talking about gay or Nogi we never, I
never traveled with a g for the military,
I don't think.
And so what I started wearing almost
all the time was Cammie pants and a tee
shirt. And what's cool is I did that
when, as soon as I started Jujitsu,
I was training with other seals that
were in Cammie pants and a tee shirt
because it didn't make sense to wear
like a Camry top. And so what's cool is,
without even knowing it when no one was
training Nogi I was actually training
Nogi because I did was just training
with guys with tee shirts on it.
Not even wearing pants, but, but
anyway, so yeah, that's what we'd wear.
Khaki pants and a tee shirt would, we
occasionally put on OPG gear occasionally,
but, but not, not very often. Uh,
either. The other thing you
got to watch out for with,
with my former organization in the seal
teams is there's guys that would go
nuts, like they didn't want to
tap cause you get major egos.
And so Kaiser could occasionally
goes psycho sometimes when I'd,
when I pit per certain
people against each other,
sometimes I'd have to basically officiate
slash be a safety officer to make sure
that no one actually got killed because
they'd be trying to kill each other and
no one wants to tap. And you have to
be like, hey man, you can't, you know,
you're about to your arms
about to get broken. Stop.
So he had to do some of that.
Uh, and I'm, I'm, I am a
bit of an instigator. Yeah,
sure.
I mean,
you see it now, I still do it on the
match today, you know, I mean if,
if there's two guys that are
going hard against each other,
but maybe they're not going super
hard. Yeah, yeah. They could go harder,
real easy to escalate that I know.
And so and so I would escalate
matches between guys as well and,
and then, you know, I just roll with
everyone. So yeah. Well the class be like,
we teach the moves just like a regular
Jiu Jitsu class, teach the moves,
go over some stuff and then roll
and that's it. Pretty simple.
Good Times. Yeah. I found that if you
can do little drills with yourself,
if you go, if you're a high level guy
and you're going to with the white belt,
especially if they're athletic,
what you do is you,
you know how like when you roll with a
guy who was maybe one level give or take
from you, you, um, or let's
say they're one level lower,
you'll kind of slowly put yourself
into better or worst situations.
You won't go all out
or nothing. Like, yeah,
but this is kind of counterintuitive to,
if you go with like a,
like a beginner beginner, but their
athletic, what you do is you try to,
you think of a finish or make your session
through that as fast as you possibly
can. So if you're like, okay,
I'm going to start on the bottom,
we're going to force how many, no.
Well, depends on what you mean.
You don't have to force it. Yeah. But
they're forcing our mock. If you say,
I'm going to finish this an arm lock,
you're gonna have to force him into that
position somewhat. You can set it up.
Sure. Yeah, exactly right.
That's what that's really the drill is
you got to set it up given what he does.
And he could be retreating the
whole time. Sure. It's going to,
so it's going to take longer. It's just,
that's just how did you get to is, but um,
that's the drill in your head rather than,
you know,
let's say an intuitive method to roll
with a white belt is, let's just go light.
Let's see what he does.
Let them get and get a good position on
you and then I'll work out or whatever,
but no, don't do that and be like, okay,
I'm going to treat this person like
a person that I have to in real life.
So do with,
and you choose whatever it a good game
to play actually that is a good game to
play.
And then you get real good at that and
going from one thing and then it's also,
I don't play that game very often.
I don't know what,
there's something that snaps in my
head sometimes when I'm like, okay,
I'm going to just smash this person.
But you know,
sometimes I'll be watching the clock
and when there's 40 seconds left I'll be
like,
all right,
I'm going to try and submit this dude in
the next 40 seconds or this is what I'm
going against someone that's good. You
know what I mean? I, that's, I honestly,
I do that with you sometimes worry and
you can feel me chilling and I'm all of a
sudden I'm like,
oh wait,
there's only 30 seconds left and I have
to go super hard to try and get you.
And sometimes I don't give myself enough
time and I said going to have to learn
to get better. Yeah. And
Yeah, me saying that, uh,
agreed. I don't do that in
training because what I heard,
my lazy instinct is I always go just
enough better than the person I'm going
against to maintain and
eventually finish them. See,
and that's good because you give the
other guy good training and that's kind of
the point with not,
you don't want to,
if you go and regularly Jitsu
class and you're like, you know,
upper belt mean like purple Brown, black
belt and you go against a white belt,
you get paired up with a white belt.
I'm not saying necessarily to do that
all the time because it's kind of,
you kind of, it's a relationship you
have with your training partners.
So if I'm like, okay, every white belt
I go against or have or any beginner,
I'm just going to go as hard
as again, it's like, Bro,
what are you doing to the
guy? Sure. Good thing.
That's why for what you're saying for
blue belts to do that is not good to have.
Who else does that? White belts, they
don't have the scale yet. Green belt,
Brown belt, black belt. That's going
to be, that's going to be like, okay,
I'm going to test my efficiency on
making this happen really quickly.
Blue Belt against the athletic white belt.
It's going to be,
it's going to be world war seven.
True.
And there's injuries that are waiting
to happen was a purple belt generally is
not going to get injured,
not going to generally injure someone
from being in a bad position. Blue Belt,
white belt, maybe it hasn't.
Bad scenarios. Yeah, and,
and so really the point in doing that is
like in a scenario like your situation
where you don't have anyone to train
with except for beginners that are all
athletic and hungry. So it's like,
okay, well what do I do? You know,
you know what's cool too. He would come
home from deployment better at Jujitsu.
Then when I left for sure that happened
on every appointment. When I came home,
I was better at Jujitsu then when I left,
but not only better than I was,
but I was in keeping with the standards
of the guys that were training with Eh.
So,
you know,
I'm rolling with Dean before I leave and
I come back and I am now doing better
than I was against Dean before I left
where he's been here training the whole
time. So that says to me
that is an effective way to
train. You know, you just,
you just, and that, so that's why there's
really no excuse. A lot of people ask,
you know, what should I do? I live four
hours away from the closest gym, man.
Get some friends,
put some mats on the ground,
watching youtube and start
training with each other.
And occasionally when you get the chance,
go somewhere to a school once a month,
once every two weeks so
you can learn. Yeah. Yeah.
And I think in your
situation is kind of a,
not necessarily unique,
but kind of a specific type of situation
where you have all the fundamentals
essentially John. So you know, like
habitual stuff, stuff that you're,
you just automatically do with
certain techniques, which is the,
the correct technique,
you know?
So I think that you'll benefit more
in that way where you can train with
beginners. When I was a
blue belt myself, yeah.
I still got a lot better when
I would be on deployment. Yeah.
And when it was a purple belt when I
was a brown belt, yeah, still still,
it's just like a little,
just a smaller version of that idea where
if you're a beginner and you're like,
okay, I've never taken you to do through,
I'm gonna start on Youtube or whatever.
I don't think you can benefit those
situations. Oh No, you can not as much.
You can't. Yeah. You definitely
not as much, but you can benefit.
I can definitely benefit. You can
definitely benefit. Yeah. It's better.
It's a thousand times better than
not doing anything and not trained.
And if you've got one person that has
that gift of being able to like understand
what's happening,
maybe you've got a wrestler in their
burrow going to help you so much for me.
You've got someone that did judo
that's gonna help you so much. Yeah.
But even if you don't, you just
start looking at it and saying, okay,
what's happening in this? What's
happening right there? Okay.
Try that on and walk on me.
And you get some of those good youtube
videos that really break things down.
Well yeah, you can learn a
lot. And I think you can,
cause I didn't have to learn that way,
luckily.
Luckily you got to train with the best
guys in the whole entire world, you know?
Hey, you know, to each their own
and then idea actually. Yeah. Um,
actually hotter Gracie, who's, you know,
we not even arguably fucking top three,
but all time ever,
he, and he was actually
telling me, he's like,
I don't have like a team of world
class guys to train with. He's like,
sometimes they trained with Braulio
sometimes cause he's in, he's in England.
Yeah. So he has like, he's like,
I only trained with my students and who
are good and they give us some training
but they're not,
I don't have world class trading partners
like my opponents do kind of thing and
raising, yeah. So men to kind of teach
their own, but all these things, yeah.
Can Be beneficial even even if
they don't necessarily seem like,
you know what I think actually this is
leading to is like you get what you make
out of. Right, exactly. Yeah. And there's,
there's people in the UFC that have
done the same thing that came from some
random camp and they're training hard
and they go and win the Connor Mcgregor.
He didn't come from, he didn't
come from Greg Jackson. Yeah.
He didn't come from American top
team. He came from, uh, you know,
their school with, with Cavenaugh and
obviously they're doing something right.
But same thing. He didn't have the, the
highest level guys to train against.
He trained, I'm not saying slagging
off their, their training partners,
but it's not, it wasn't a known camp when
he came around. Right, right. He, he's so,
he's a guy like that. Uh, Max
Holloway. He's out in Hawaii,
right?
He's training hard,
but he's coming out here winning the
UFC championship based on, you know,
his training partners.
So I think guys that,
that actually understand what
they need to do. They do it,
they get it done. They don't
make any excuses. No excuses.
You have at the end of the day, that's
it. Right. Check. Next question.
With life decisions,
is it better to be decisive and take
actions to move forward even if sometimes
those decisions are wrong as opposed to
being paralyzed by indecision and fear,
thus getting maneuvered on by life?
I ask this because I struggle with life
decisions and have trouble committing to
one path duty,
eclectic interests.
After listening to your podcast,
I'm thinking it's better to be aggressive
and maneuver on the battlefield of
life as long as I'm prepared to adapt
rather than sitting around and letting
circumstance dictate my actions.
Well,
it sounds like you kind of answered his
own question there, which is good. Yes,
it is better to be aggressive.
It's better to be decisive.
This does not mean burning bridges. And
I think we've talked about this before.
It doesn't mean that you just,
you just say,
I'm quitting my job right now because
I'm going to go start a new life as a
whatever your new job is going to be,
right?
I'm going to start a business selling
widgets and I'm just going to go all in
because I'm committed.
Sure. Well, you, you know,
how long has it takes to produce
those widgets and what are, you know,
so there's a lot of issues with that.
You know, it's, there's a way though to,
to mitigate risk on your
decisions. And actually at the, uh,
at the camp we were in, up in Maine, there
was a lot of guys that were, you know,
listen to the podcast and
one of them really good,
really good guy.
He was talking to me about
his business and the business,
which I'm not going to go into any
details, but he's basically saying, look,
I've got this business. It's going
well. I want it to do better.
And I'm kind of weighing this
decision between bringing on,
he says,
no,
I'm going to bring on like six people
to really help expand and grow and all
that stuff. He said, but if I do that
and we have a couple rough, you know,
if we hit some bad luck, I might be
upside down and not be able to handle it.
And what I really am scared of is like,
that's not just me,
but it's now it's my family.
I got a wife and I got kids and now I'm
hedging the comfort and safety of my
family so I don't know what
to do. And I said, okay,
well do you have to go all in?
Right?
Do you have to turn around tomorrow and
go, you know what? We're going all in.
I'm going to hire these six people,
we're going to expand.
And hopefully if everything goes right,
we'll do really well.
You don't have to do that. You don't
have to put that much on the table.
Instead I said, I said, well,
how many people do you actually
really need right now? And he said,
probably one or two. And I was like, okay,
why don't you bring all in one and and
start to see where that goes and be
prepared to look for another
person to bring on to.
And then as those two people work out
and you're starting to fill their labor
every day, and they're, they have work
to do because you're expanding the cool,
bring on three. And, and guess what?
If you hit a hiccup and things start
going sideways for whatever reason,
that's cool.
You don't have those
additional four people or three
people on board that you're
paying payroll to every month,
which is normally what kills businesses
or one of the common things that kills
businesses. So it's the same. So, so
that's, that's a good example, right?
And he was, he thought to himself and
he looked at me, said, absolutely,
I'm going to go do that. And so he's
probably back at his job right now,
running his business and probably
hiring a person to start expanding,
not hiring six people and putting all
of his chips on the table where it's a
cool gamble. Let's say the percentage of
winning winning is 70% you're like, yeah,
I'm just going to do it.
There's a 30% chance you lose and lose,
and now your now your family
has no house and no food.
So that's not what we want to do.
So why not just put some of your chips
on the table and you can still win and
make a little bit? You still,
you still improve your position.
So we got to do that with life too.
Like I said,
you don't quit your job to start
building widgets when you don't know what
you're doing. You got to, why not just
build the widgets in your spare time?
I start putting those things on the
internet, start seeing how they sell,
start getting a little income from
them, let them grow. And then finally,
when you feel like the
balance start to tip,
maybe there'll be a last minute
jump where you'd be like, okay,
now I'm going to go for it. But what
you're committing to is something solid,
something tangible, and something
that's making money, right?
We're not jumping in and committing
to something that's an unknown.
We're going to commit some to
something that's known and,
and I think it's important to note
that that right there is not a lack of
commitment. And this is, you hear these
like you know, people on the interwebs,
there'll be like,
you know why you have made yet?
Because you haven't 80 100% that's
why you, if you want to do it,
you got to commit with everything you've
got. Well and so what people think is,
okay,
well I'm just gonna quit my job because
I'm going to go for it but commit and
then I'll be successful. Cause this
guy over here told me if I committed,
I'd be successful.
It's actually not true.
You can be 1000% committed to
something and you can still fail.
I got bad news for you.
That's the reality. You know,
that's the reality of do you think that
people at blackberry weren't committed
to their game? You know what I mean? You
know, but what happened to blackberry?
It's it's you. They were,
they were committed but they
made some bad decisions.
And guess what? Now blackberry is not
really in the game anymore. Well, they,
I think they change games.
I'm not 100% sure,
but people think that that because you
didn't quit your job and go all in and
put all your chips on the table.
In fact, you're not committed.
And I actually don't agree with that.
And I'll get,
here's my example if,
okay.
I think that commitment is actually
harder to do when it's a long term
commitment that you're going,
okay, you know what, I'm gonna,
I'm gonna stay at my job,
but I'm gonna work three hours
a day on this other thing.
I'm going to be manufactured with maybe
making my widgets three hours a day.
And when I get home at
10 o'clock at night,
I'm going to go until one o'clock
in the morning making my widgets.
That's commitment.
It's actually smart commitment.
It actually in some ways takes more
commitment to do that than it does just to
quit your job and say, I'm all
in. Because now you're holding,
you're balancing all these
different things you're carrying,
you're shouldering more of a burden.
So that actually takes more commitment.
The problem is that people,
they, they get weak.
And after the fourth night of making
widgets at 10 o'clock at night, they go,
yeah, I'm gonna, I'm good.
It's cool to have a job. I
have a job. And so that's week.
I, you know, an example would
be what if you could get in
excellent physical
condition in three hours,
but it was just like the hardest three
hours that you could imagine thinking
about that and your body would transform
from whatever crap condition you're in
right now into a specimen and it's
going to take three hours of just,
yeah. How many more people
would be an amazing condition?
I don't know. I think a ton more because
committing for three hours to something,
even if it was going to be super bad,
people would be able to do it.
What takes more commitment and the reason
everyone's not walking around like a
perfect specimen is because
it doesn't take three hours.
It doesn't take three weeks.
It doesn't take three months.
It takes a daily grind that goes on for
years that you have to hold the line on,
on the way you eat,
on the way you exercise on your life.
And that takes real commitment.
Yes.
So it isn't a lack of commitment.
It's planning.
It isn't a lack of commitment.
It is mitigating risk and don't confuse.
Again,
I think that the person that commits to
something and still maintains this other
income stream, for example, that
person is at least as committed,
if not more committed than the
person says, you know what? Screw it.
I'm going all in over here. I'm forgetting
about, you know, quitting my job.
But that's not a smart move and it takes
more. That's actually an easier, well,
that's my point. It's easier in
many ways to go, you know what?
I'm quitting his day job. I'm quitting my
nine to five. I'm sick of that cubicle.
I'm sick of that construction site.
I'm just going all in over here.
That is an easier move.
That takes less commitment than saying,
I'm going to shoulder the
burden of working 15 1820
hours a day for the next two
years until I can get this thing stood up
enough to where I can execute it. Yeah.
Yes. It's almost like people were
conflating the commitment. You know?
It's like the almost people want to
want to do a big show of commitment by
quitting their job, but it's more
of just a show of commitment.
You're committed or
you're not kind of thing.
And then so a lot of times with these
big shows of commitment comes just an
immense amount of stupidity,
you know? Yeah, yeah. Meanwhile,
you can either commit or don't
commit, you know? Yeah, sure.
If you don't quit your job and you make
widgets and you don't commit, sure.
It's like, all right, you got, you can
facilitate your non commitment. Yeah.
I dig here.
Do your real job,
your nine to five job as an enabler to
you not committing. Yeah. Fully. Yeah.
But by no means is that
you know, no proof. Yeah.
And it's important to
note that don't confuse,
and this is another mistake that people
make mistakes on either ends of the
spectrum.
The other one is don't confuse planning
and mitigating risk with not taking
action,
because that can happen to,
you have to make things happen every
single day. That's what you have to do.
If you don't take action.
If you don't move,
which is what this guy's asking about,
then yeah,
you're paralyzed and you're
never going to get anywhere.
All you have to do is
chip away at that thing.
You got to make a little bit of movement
every day. You want to write a book,
and this is something I'm familiar
with now, cause I'm writing books.
I'm writing another book right
now and you know what I gotta do?
I gotta chip away at that thing every day,
every day,
every day. There's your commitment,
thousand words a day, 45 minutes,
maybe an hour. That's what
it takes. And guess what?
If I can't give that hour for
whatever reason, guess what?
I'm going to get to 20 minutes.
I'm going to get 30 minutes,
I'm going to get
something to get in there.
I'm going to do work because I'm going
to be close to my goal than it was. Yeah.
That's the way it is. Yeah, man. And
I think you got to see that live.
Didn't your honor?
It was my honor.
That's, uh, but that's where it happens.
Where else is it going to happen? Right.
Yeah. We were flying back from Maine.
I was, you know, echoes cruising. Good.
Yeah. I think I fell asleep a couple of
times. Yeah. You were kind of in and out,
but I wasn't, I was hammering, I was,
I was doing what I have to do because
if I don't do it, then when's that?
When I'm going to get that hour. That was,
that was four hours I had right there.
Flight. Technically five. Yeah.
Couldn't get my computer out for
the first little bit. Oh yeah.
They didn't let you, so
whatever. All good. Yeah.
It was kind of at time till it's peeking
over your shoulder, like reading all,
let's talk. Go. Right. And
then they see a, what was it?
I felt the named Kenny Williamson
in there. Goes writing right now.
Look to this good man composed.
Yeah,
I think that all that sounds
like kind of obvious. You know,
when you're saying it, I'm
like, yeah, okay. Yeah, yeah,
yeah. Got It. Or, you know,
or at least the part where it's like,
it's a daily thing.
Like you got to have a progress, you
know, like you got to take that step,
you know, do, it sounds obvious,
but man, how many times,
and I didn't know this is like my
friends and you know, whatever, uh,
you go on, I don't know,
online or whatever, and you
see people complaining about,
you know, stuff never happens
for me. You know, FML,
FML means yes, stuff never
happens to you. That's right.
And stuff never happens for you.
That's right.
That is life doesn't happen for you in
life. You got to go and make it. You know,
I've explained to my kids,
you want to make money,
you have to take that money from someone
else. You have to take it from them.
Then people aren't just gonna
walk up and give you money. Right.
That doesn't happen.
That's never happened to me in my life.
No one has ever walked up
and given me money. I mean,
you got to take that money that
they got to give it to you,
that you've got to make them, you
got to take it from them. Yeah.
They want that money to,
so what are you going to give them that's
going to allow you to take it from him?
Yeah, that, that so yeah. Guess what?
Nothing's, nothing happens for you.
That's right. Nothing does happen
for you. You have to make it happen.
That's the default aggressive mindset
that you are going to make things happen.
I'm not gonna sit around and wait for
things to happen and it's not going to
happen. Yeah. It's not
going to happen. Oh,
well guess what?
I read a story about this such and such
a person and they just walked into this,
you know,
agency and they thought they looked did
a really good job and now they're famous.
Okay. That's great. Base your life on
that percentage chance of happening.
It's not happening. Yeah. I actually, I
look at that and just think the match,
the chances of anything like
that happened to me or zero,
nothing good is going to
happen to me like that,
that I'm just going to get a good deal.
Like that's not happening. Zero. Yeah,
so if, if you're going to get it, you're
going to have to make it happen. Yeah.
Next question. You're saying that should
be the red flag right there then. Right.
Basically for the, for someone
who's like nothing, you know,
when am I going to get my big break or,
or you know,
nothing happens for me kind of thing.
That should be the red flag, right?
When it's like, yeah. Yeah.
Seems you're talking about
the fact that you're not,
that things aren't coming
to you. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That should be a real big red flag.
Nothing is going to come to you.
Not Happening,
not happening.
You got to go and make things happen
and once you have that attitude,
I'll tell you what, it's a game
changer. It's a game changer.
Once you realize that that book
that's so good, that's in your head,
it's not going to write itself. Once
you realize that widget that you have,
this plan for isn't going to build
itself, then you'll realize like, okay,
I'm going to have to make these things
happen, and even then, guess what?
You can make a widget that no one wants
to buy and you can write a book that no
one wants to know, wants to read,
and if you're not okay with that,
which is another thing that
happens, people say, well, you know,
no one will like it. Okay,
well if that's what you think,
well then don't even ride it unless
you want to write it for yourself.
Then write it for yourself and cool.
Be be proud, be stoked to be happy.
It's interesting. Let's say a
book book, right? For example,
this kind of reminds me of where you know
how, let's say, I don't know me, I'm a,
let's say, Oh, I'm a, I'm a
pretty good writer. In fact,
I even wrote a book before,
whatever. And then my friend
on Instagram, Facebook,
whatever, someone, my neighbor,
whatever, they write a book and they,
they release it and then they write
another one and May, let's say,
it's not even really that good,
but it's out there. They're like,
look at my new book. And you know, they
got people support. Oh, that's awesome.
You wrote a book and,
and I'm meanwhile,
I'm like kind of sour grapes a
little bit. I'm like, should I am?
I'm a better writer then in that person.
Meanwhile, I didn't write any more.
I'm over here. Yeah, I wrote back
in the day, long time ago, you know?
But you know, I'm in it. I'm
saying I'm in that arena, you know,
and I'm kind of in my mind hating on this.
There's people that hate on him that never
even wrote a book in the first place.
Yeah. Oh Man, I'm a better
writer. I'm a better film guy.
I'm a better writer, I'm a
better fighter. Whatever.
They had all kinds of people doing that.
All kinds of people that will just
be saying, Oh, you know, I, I,
I was a better whatever.
Fighter, Jujitsu player,
a carpenter, a, whatever,
you name it. Yeah. Meanwhile,
taking no action software engineer.
I could have done that.
Why didn't you? Yeah, exactly
right. I'll tell you why.
Because you weren't committed. Yes. And
the commitment that we're talking about,
is it night. Yeah. At night or early,
early in the morning or in the middle of
the day, whatever it, how you said like,
you're,
you're not doing these
enormous shows of commitment.
Like either you're committed or
you're not, and if you're committed,
it's going to show itself by your
action. You know, allows people, again,
back to the guy who's like hating on his
neighbor doing quote unquote mediocre
work. Like, oh, that's John, that's not
that good hitting on it. You know what?
This just made me think of this.
Sometimes you'd meet a guy that was say,
I'm going to seal training and,
and they'd kind of be brag about it and
you could see in their eyes that that
right there was good enough for them.
Oh be like,
I'm going to seal seal team training.
Yeah.
No one had caused a seal team training,
but that's the kind of person cause
they just want to write. And you, I,
I'd hear guy, you know,
guys saying that, yeah,
I'm going to seal training the guys that
generally have a better chance or guys
that, you know, you say, oh, what are
you doing in the navy? And they say, Oh,
you know, I'm um, you know, just got
done with a school and I'm starting, uh,
hoping to go to seal training. You know,
the, the, you have to pry it out of him.
That guy's a better chance.
The guy that's already bragging,
basically indirectly bragging because
he's implying that he's going to make it.
Those guys going to have a
little bit more of a rough five.
Now this doesn't mean they're not, this
doesn't mean don't be confident. Yeah.
But that's what I'm saying is some
people that are like, I'm going for it.
They're happy with just saying,
I'm committed.
I quit my job and this
is one way to do it.
They're happy to let everyone know that.
Yes.
But what they're not happy to do is grind.
That's what they're not happy to do.
And that's where, that's where you,
that's where you make your money, right.
Or where you make your goods are
where you become successful. Yeah,
there was, it is, it doesn't matter,
but alluding to somebody and they
were talking about, um, like commit,
like people have goals.
I want to be a singer or whatever.
I want to be a CEO. I was
wondering, I want to be a CEO
or you can form an LLC today and you
can be become the CEO. Exactly. Right.
So that's kind of part of the
point right there. It's like, okay,
you want to be a feel because you
see all this cool stuff on wherever,
above being a CEO.
But really what you're pursuing
isn't necessarily being the it is,
but what you're pursuing,
where you're going to end up and where
you're going to find success as a CEO,
if you're pursuing that day to
day of being a CEO, it's like, oh,
I said this before and it's, it's
on the surface, it's lame, but it's,
it's actually really accurate.
Like, if you want to be a gangster,
you have to do gangster stuff every day.
It's not just like posing with your guns.
It's like you got to kind of,
you gotta put in that work kind of thing,
you know? So if you're going to be like,
you can't just be Jocko and start a
podcast and just in, in, you know,
put out a book and that's it,
and start collecting money.
It's not like that you gotta you
gotta go through to, you know,
however old you are,
many hears other steps involved.
Exactly right this day. And I
used to joke about, uh, you know,
cause when we started Ashkelon Front
obviously, which is me and him,
and we'd see some other guy out there
to be a CEO of something and we'd be
saying, well, that guy, a CEO of,
and you look at their company
and the company has them,
the only one person or
three people it, bro, you're
on the CEO. Hey, I'm the CEO of Jocko
podcast. The whole, it's just you and me.
There's no CEO going on here.
Yeah. We're cruising too hard.
Yeah, yeah. That deal.
You've got to focus on the right things
as opposed to the wrong thing. Check.
Next question.
Jocko.
I coach high school football,
which should I do with the star athlete
who segregates himself and won't
participate in hard drills or it won't
participate hard in drills. Yeah.
Now this one,
I actually thankfully remembered that I
said I would do this because when I got
this,
this is a Twitter question and I responded
to this Twitter question in one word.
So you know, he says, I got this guy, Star
athlete, he won't participate in drills.
What should I do with them?
I responded in one word
bench thought that so,
so of course, you know, then people
start saying, well you know it's, and,
and I was like, yeah, I know. We're on
Twitter, right? We're on Twitter. Uh,
there's more to it than what's happening.
I just answered 798 questions and this
was 799 so I'm not going to go into full
detail. But then as people were kind
of chime in and I was like, okay, I'll,
I'll answer this on the podcast so
we can go into it a little bit more.
Because yes, your coach, your leader,
and obviously I talk
about this all the time,
leadership is a nuance thing.
It takes balance,
it takes maneuvering, it takes
chess playing, it takes mental,
Jujitsu, it takes all those things, right?
So the obvious answer of just like bench,
that's my meat head answer.
And fundamentally we'll get to it,
but,
and fundamentally that may be the result,
but let's dive into it a little bit
more. Who's The kid? What's his deal?
What's his background? What's his
attitude? Where's he coming from?
What's his family like life?
Or what's his family life like?
What is,
what's his past performance?
What's his record?
What year is he in school?
I mean there's all kinds of
things we need to know, right?
So now once we've sort of figured out
what he liked now that any one of those
things,
any one of those variables is going to,
is going to change our course
of action a little bit.
Because being a leader doesn't mean you
get to follow a cookie cutter results or
quick cookie cutter solutions to things,
right?
You're dealing with human beings and
every single human being is different.
And every single human being has a
little to them that you cannot predict.
So we're dealing with a kid.
Guess what? A 16 year old boy,
that kid is even more unpredictable
and even more crazy than most, right?
Cause he's got testosterone
flowing through his system.
He's chasing girls, he's,
he's just going crazy.
He's not secure with himself yet.
He's got zits on his face. He's,
you know, he's got things going on,
he's got issues. And so this kid is crazy
and we're trying to deal with them. Now.
Most kids can get,
you know,
they get through that and they're still
participating in the team. This gets not,
so one of the first
things I always say this,
you got somebody that's not stepping up
into leadership position or they're not
wandering. You put them in charge of
it. Hmm. You know, you say, Hey, echo,
I want you to run this drill.
I think the way up,
I'm watching you perform on the field,
but I think you could really
lead this drill. Well,
I want you to lead this drill and show
these guys what's up, right? Oh, so,
so you know what I mean? Like you
got a little fired up face on your,
you're just there. So that might take his
attitude. And now instead of me saying,
Hey Echo, you've got to do
this drill like everyone else.
I already know that you
don't want to do that.
So I'm elevating you a little bit and
your ego, a little push, a little massage,
and maybe you feel good about that
now. And I say, Hey, you know,
you can run this drill faster than
anyone else. I want you to lead it.
I want you to show them how to do it. I
want you to make our team better. Boom.
All of a sudden you're getting
a little fired up. So that's,
that's one solution type,
right?
I'm just getting kind of a broad solution
types on. Another solution type is, is,
and this is real easy,
real easy,
is when you're talking to someone that
you want to improve their performance,
you don't go to them and say, Hey, uh,
you need to get better because you're
just right now you're letting the whole
team down, right? And you're
just, you think you're all good.
You think you're so good
that you don't need to coach.
You don't need to run drills with the
team. You need to run drills to the team.
Now your attitude is what are you talking
about? So instead of saying that I,
again, I'm going to eagle you up
a little bit and be say, Hey man,
I'm going to talk to you.
I've got to talk to you because I see so
much potential with you, with your game.
I see your athletic ability and I see
the way that the other guys on the team
look at you. You might not sense it.
They look up to you. You're a leader.
Whether you want to be a leader or not.
And the potential that you have in is
as an athlete is not going to come to
fruition on,
unless you at least get some of
your potential as a leader in line.
So the reason I want you to run these
drills isn't to make you better.
I already know you're good.
I already know you're good at the drills.
The reason I want you to run these drills,
Chi wants you to be even better.
I want you to reach your potential.
And by the way you help and run these
drills is going to make the team better.
And the better the team does,
the better you're going to do.
The more scouts we're going
to here looking at you.
So there's that,
and obviously I'm gonna explain to him
why the drills are important for him and
for the team and for AML and the team
together for everyone to reach their
potential. So those
were, those are good too.
And I guess overall,
broadly what I'd be doing this
whole time is talking to the person,
talking to the individual,
trying to figure out
what his reasons were for not
wanting to participate in the drills.
And then countering those reasons
with logical answers and you know,
saying,
Hey,
here's why it's important and explaining
it to them and then eventually you're
going to get to a point where my
coaching, my explaining, my maneuvering,
my mental Jujitsu,
none of it's worked and he's still
telling me I'm not running the drills.
I don't need to. Cool. Ben,
next question. You know what I mean? Well
you played ball. What do you think? Yeah,
cause I didn't play football.
Yeah, no, that's exactly
right. I would, I would think,
and I'm trying to put myself in the
mindset back when I was in high school,
I remember going into my senior year,
so you have,
oh we had some kind of summer training,
so it was really like high school summer
training. That was for fall. Okay.
Um, and that was like a camp
situation, but no summer training,
which was like after spring and
stuff in it. And what they'd call it,
they call it technique sessions.
And all it was was like, you know,
I played in high school was
kind of like a slap back,
which is a hybrid running back
wide receiver type. And um,
so the technique sessions were just
kind of passing drills and you know,
just hand stuff and maybe
even some footwork. But it
was kind of fun. It was just,
you know,
the quarterback who was there and the
receivers in the Ryan Beck catch passes,
run routes and stuff and you know, for
like, I dunno, 45 minutes, hour and um,
so I remember going into my senior
year and they're talking about, yeah,
technique sessions this
year, whatever, whatever.
And I remember I was just talking to
jade, my brother, and I was like, yeah,
technique sessions.
It's the kind where if you don't go,
you don't get in big trouble or nothing.
It's just strongly encouraged, you know,
that kind of stuff. And I'm like,
yeah, I'm not going to those kind of,
cause that was real.
I had done it with a man.
I done well as a junior and I knew that
now as a senior I'm really going to do
well, whatever, whatever. That's,
that was my little thought.
I don't need to go to those. So
I was like, I was like, yeah,
I'm not going into those with
this kind of tone, that line.
That's for people who are trying
to train to get better. Me,
I'm already dope kind of thing.
You know? And Jay goes, he goes,
oh yeah, like we're super sarcastic, like
almost offended. He was like, Oh yeah,
cause you don't need that,
huh? And then he said, yeah,
because you're just so
much better than everyone.
Actually I think he said both of those and
I was like, Bro, it hit me really hard.
I was like, Dang, he's
right. Even if even if like,
even if I really believe which it,
it's dumb to believe that I
won't benefit from that training.
Even if it's like I'm just
like, yeah, I'm, I'm, I'm
better than you. My whole team,
by the way, the team sport, we all
work together to win this stuff.
All you guys, I'm better than all you
guys. Yeah. That's the feeling I had.
He hit me real hard. I was like sure
I didn't miss any of them. Now I'm,
and I'm committed to. So there
was that. Um, so in that,
in that mindset, right. Going in,
cause that's probably what it is. Yeah.
It might be just that.
And it makes sense like we're in your
mind if you don't get it brought to your
attention, like that's really what it
is. I don't need to do these drills.
I'm scoring touchdowns every single game.
Why am I doing these drills that all
these non touchdown scoring people are
doing, you know, just put me
in when it's time to score,
touch that kind of an attitude,
you know,
that's probably what it is or making
tackles or whatever the position is.
I Dunno. Um, so just like how you said,
make him kind of in charge of it, kind
of like this guy, what's his name is Jim.
I know Jim, you know,
take these guys and show them how it's
done kind of thing in practice because
practices, cause yeah, imagine,
imagine if you say I'm not
going to go to this thing.
And the coach came up and he
said, hey echo are you, you know,
you missed your practices and you're like,
yeah, you know. And he was like, hey man,
I need you to set the example and
really show these guys how it's done and
you're not even showing up.
Yeah.
Even in mate me back in those days,
if you would have left out that you
didn't show up part, leave that part out.
That would have compelled me way more.
Like if you're like you man, you're,
you're over here as a junior killing
it and now it's about to be your senior
year. You show you guys how it's
done. I'd be like no. Yeah. You know,
cause it's like feeding the wheel
kind of thing and boom out. Oh yeah.
Big Time Sheet. Take charge
in Pop Warner football,
which is, you know, younger guys
in I played for the Koloa Rams.
Yeah. Sound ruthless. They
are still are by the way. Um,
and so my coach's name is coach
Scovel and he had this kind of,
it's kind of like a policy kind of the
thing where when you do jumping jacks,
when you do drills like, um, they call
them gras drills, it's just like, oh,
you do this stuff,
you role,
you do these things and while you do this
in practice, and even before the game,
when you're warming up, you yell
as loud as you can. That's it.
You yell a little kids just yelling,
getting that stuff for his reasons.
And it worked. Man.
We're, we're good. And um,
so what I would do is I
would try to be the dude,
like yell as loud as I possibly can to
be the loudest guy during the entire,
whatever you're doing, you're just
yelling the entire time. The drills. Yeah.
When it's your turn, not, not
if you're standing, you know,
stand up in line. Got It.
And then the front. Yeah. So the
coach stands in front of three guys,
three lines, and the guys in
the front are doing the drills.
So he holds the ball and you go, oh, and
you just basically shuffle your feet.
And he goes like that. Then you turn and
then you come back and he goes this way,
turn. And then he goes down. Then
you basically sprawl, you know, boom,
stand back a bit, you know, and
then he goes, okay, like that.
And then the three guys run. Now it's the
next guys. You see what I'm saying? So,
and when you're running, you gotta
yell too. So that's been good.
Cardiovascular work. Yeah. To be
yelling, cause you can't bring as much.
What it does is gets you in the habit
of just going heart, heart, every play,
you know? And when you're
done, you don't have to yell.
You're cruising your esteem, getting rid.
And when one is go time, it's go time.
And habitually. That's how it was man. It
was, it really worked. And um, so anyway,
when
I would yell is that in the coach would
do this to a lot of kids when UDL super
loud,
you know,
you can just see here that guy yelling
above everybody would give that guy
attention. Well, this guy who's
getting a hot, yeah, look at this,
it lose this guy and now the next guy,
he's going to try to out yell that guy,
go harder, go harder. So it's
that same idea, you know,
you give that guy props for working hard
or showing everybody how it's done kind
of thing.
And it's like Ben,
who's going to keep that shit up and
everyone's going to want it. In fact,
Jeff did me like that this week in
training. So I go in and desks like, okay,
after training is like everybody, you
know, Glover, yeah, he um, you know,
you do some pushups or like he'll make
you do some pushups or whatever. And I'm,
he's like, okay, do the
triangle drill. You know, when
you're, you're on your back,
you rock back, you do a
triangle, you rock back again,
go to triangle the other side. So, oh, all
levels are in their beginnings as well.
And I'm, so I'm doing it and he goes, oh,
everybody in the middle of, he goes, stop,
watch. I'll echo does it. And I'm like,
if I didn't see what was going on here,
I would feel really empowered to
show it for now. And, and you know,
so he successfully pulled that off
as far as the feeling in my head.
Two grown adult fitness. Were you doing
them? Yeah, it was doing it with everybody
when he pauses the whole class and said,
watch how he does it, you know, so it's,
it's the exact same concept up your game.
A little bit technique
should every bloody yeah, no,
it's good man.
That works then like a,
and the point there is even if you know
that that's what they're doing to you,
it's still kind of works.
Hey,
if you were the type of coach that had
already had this happen before and like
you just benched guy and the coach had
the reputation that you don't play around
this, what would have happened in the
first place really? Would it? I agree.
I think so. So you, you may have to
set the example at some point. Yeah.
The only drawback of that potentially is,
um,
you could cause in high school a lot of
the times like you can have one or two
guys on the team,
sometimes even one guy on the team that'll
dictate the outcome of the game where
if this guy's playing, you'll,
you'll probably win. If he's not,
you'll probably lose and you, you have
those dynamics in high school. Um,
so if you run that risk
where, I mean, unless you,
if you're looking at a bigger picture,
well I guess this is a bad example.
If the guy,
if you,
if you as a coach run things
in a certain way where you,
where you don't allow any slack.
Yeah.
Then the probability of this
occurring is going to be less. Yeah.
It can be done for sure. Like
you know, it's a funny story.
Life tell sometimes as we were doing
desert training and long story short,
there's a opportunity to have guys take
a break and go to town and have some
beer and get a good meal before
the field training exercises start.
And that's normal what everyone does.
But we didn't do that. We didn't
take a break, didn't go get food,
didn't go get beers and nothing.
We just got after it and I didn't really
think much of it. But life was like,
yeah, of course we wanted
to go, but no one will.
No one wanted to ask you cause it was
just like, yeah, no slack, we're not,
obviously we're not, we're not here to
train and get some, we're not here to,
you know, go into town and drink a beer.
No. And it's kind of funny looking back,
but I think that that you can establish
yourself as a type of leader that's just
not going to allow like
what are you talking about?
You don't want to do the drills.
But it starts with the little things like
who knows what this, this kid, you know,
maybe he didn't want to
put on his practice Jersey
and he wanted to wear this.
You know what I mean? Just like
little things, little things build up.
And eventually he seemed
just like a normal kid,
just like a five year old that
pushes the envelope with everything.
Can't get worry about,
well, what can I get away?
Can I get away with that and
what can I get away with?
People like to push the envelope right
on my life, man. Yeah, no Slattery. Yeah,
but you can go too far with no
slack of course, and you now,
now everyone hates you as a coach
because you just don't understand.
You don't listen and you're a jerk.
You've,
you've gone too far in one direction
or you've gone too far in the other
direction. Balanced dichotomy. A
leadership. Get some. Yeah. That's true.
Next question,
Jocko.
Have you ever had a person you couldn't
get through to someone that you couldn't
manipulate? Then what? What do
you do when you can't get through?
Well, yeah, of course.
I've had people that I could not get
through to and generally speaking,
these people are like level 12 arrogance.
That's what they are. Giant ego.
That's what causes this.
There was quite a few seal
leaders that I dealt with.
I shouldn't say quite a few.
There were several seal leaders that I
dealt with that were like that and have
several business leaders that I've
dealt with that were like that.
In podcast number five,
I read that counseling letter,
corrective measures to a guy
that was really arrogant.
And despite that letter,
he did not change and he got fired.
So what do you do when you've got someone
that you can't get through to you?
You fire them if they are, if, and
here's what you gotta do is what,
what makes that tricky
is that some people,
and this May this,
this make people freak out.
There's some people that there's such
good performers that even though they're
slightly negative on maybe
their team participation,
but they're so good that, that it
offsets their negativity, right?
And that happens. It happens. You know
what happens with saint salespeople,
salespeople are,
are in order to be in a sales position,
you've got to be confident.
You gotta be aggressive.
You've got to be somewhat arrogant,
right? You gotta believe in yourself.
And so some salespeople take that to
the extreme where they're just like,
I don't need to listen to what you're
telling me. The new procedures are,
screw that. I'm the one that's
doing the big dollars over here.
How much you follow my procedures
boys, right? So, so that happens.
Well then what you gotta do is you've
got to look does is this guy producing so
now that can create problems within
the team and you have to balance those
things. Is this guy,
uh, is the negativity,
is creating offset by the awesome
productivity Vinnie's doing.
And furthermore, if the
guys that good, hey,
maybe we should be modeling some things
after them. I got no problem with that.
If you're the best performer,
cool, I want to imitate you.
I want to get my people to imitate you.
So that happens at the other
place where you might see it.
A similar situation is a leader that
does really good with their relationships
down the chain of command,
for instance,
but really has bad relations up
the chain of command. So again,
you've got to ask yourself,
okay, if I fire this leader,
how many of these people that he has great
relationships are now going to leave?
And what kind of detriment
is that to the team?
That can also happen with someone that's
doesn't debt treats their people like
crap, but up the chain of command,
everyone thinks it's great and,
and he's getting the mission
done by the way, right?
He's a slave driver and he's creating
total animosity between him and his team,
but he's accomplishing the mission.
So now what you do, there's risk.
Everyone could quit. There's
rescue, good fireman.
Now you don't accomplish the mission
anymore. This is why leadership is hard.
And this is why you have to
balance everything. You have
to balance those things.
But talked about it a bunch of times. If
you get someone, you're coaching them,
you mentor them, you do everything you
can, you have flank them, you do Jujitsu,
mental Jujitsu on them.
You try and get them squared away.
And eventually if you can't,
you weigh against, you know,
how it's gonna affect the situation.
And then in many cases,
you've got to let them go. And we
fired, you know, we fired five,
saw plenty of seals, get fired
from leadership positions. Um,
and, and same thing with,
you know, obviously you work
with consulting businesses.
We see all kinds of people getting fired
because they're either not capable of
doing their job,
they're too arrogant and
they don't recognize that
things are going sideways and
they're just thinking that they're
doing everything perfectly. No,
that's not gonna work out well
for you. You know, what did
I think it was Lafe did,
uh,
someone asked him, uh, you
know, when do you know, when's
that line where it's like,
when it's time to fire someone.
And he was like, in a nutshell,
there's a lot to it, but in
a nutshell, which I thought
was dope. Um, he said it's,
you know, you're at that point where
you, where you fire someone when, um,
when you don't feel bad about it,
right? So it's like, yeah, you,
you every tried everything. And,
and there's also people boots,
there's some validity to this that say
the first time you think you should fire
someone, you should fire him. That's
the other end of the spectrum. Right?
And what that means is when you're looking
at someone and you're going, man, okay,
I can save them,
I can help them.
That's the kind of advice you
give to someone that's, that's a,
that's got a maternal instinct,
right? That you meet someone, Hey,
I know what this guy is just a good guy
and everyone on my team is great and
everyone's going to do great job.
You can't tell that person what
Lafe and normally tell people, which
is when you feel good about it,
you should fire him because that person
will never feel good about firing
anybody just to see what I'm saying.
Cause he just said, dude, this guy,
I know he's going to make it. It. No,
he's going to come around, you know I,
and then they, then they start playing
the, the extreme ownership game, which is,
you know, if I would've given
echo a better direction,
he would have been able to do this.
It's my fault.
I've given an echo 17 re iterations of
this and he still didn't complete it
correctly. He's fired. That's the
way it works, right? There's, yeah.
So balance. So that
spectrum of, of, you know,
being within the confines of
being justified, firing somebody,
a certain type of person, you got to say
when you don't feel bad about it. Right,
right. I mean, that's like a
fire heavy type dude. Right.
But there's also someone,
the reason that you shouldn't feel bad
about it is because I've done everything
I can do to help you, which
takes work. It takes effort,
it takes tact.
It takes hard conversations because
it's hard for me to go and say Echo.
You know, I've been, I've been looking
at your videos lately and they're,
they're not really what we're looking for,
right. I don't want to say that to you.
And you know, I, it's uncomfortable and
we're kind of like, you know, we, we,
we want to get along. So instead I'm like,
yeah, I call that the video was good,
man. Yeah, it's good, but I'm
not telling you the truth.
And then over time our videos are looking
good enough. And eventually I said,
you know what?
You know we're not,
no one's buying our videos anymore
and we haven't gotten a new contracts.
So guess what? I'm going to have
to let you go. And you're like,
what you're talking about? You said,
all the videos I made were good.
Now you're firing me. Maybe you need to
be able to become a better salesperson.
Right? Whereas if I had
the hard conversation early
and said, hey, [inaudible],
you know, I know you're
creative and I appreciate that,
but we also need to get the
message across for our clients.
Obviously fabricating a business
where we're making videos for clients,
which I know we don't really do a lot
of anymore. Occasionally you do it,
but yeah, you got to, you got to
have the harder conversations earlier.
If I'm the type of person that doesn't
like to have the hard conversations,
once again, I never feel good
about it because I never,
I never gave you any advice. So it
always feels bad for me to fire someone.
But if you're following
good leadership tactics,
then absolutely true. When you get to a
point where you've got to fire somebody,
you won't feel bad about it. Cause you
know you've done everything you can,
you know, you've coached
them, mentor them,
and you know that if
you keep them on board,
you are negatively impacting
your team, which is bad. Yeah.
And then go down to the other side of
the spectrum still within the confines of
being justified in firing somebody,
by the way.
But on the other side of the spectrum,
you get how you say that,
what do you call it? The maternal instinct
versus instinct. The person who can,
like, they're just super hard on
themselves maybe. Or they're, you know,
like even if you did do everything
you can and you still like,
I could have done more, you
know, it's my fault, not his,
I feel like I let them down as a leader
and it gave them 17 counseling. Chits,
they don't belong here. They
can't do their job. Stop. Yeah.
I mean while they're going home
laughing at you or whatever. But yeah,
you get that kind of personality.
So it's kind of like how you said you got
to balance it. You gotta be like, okay,
you've got to recognize, okay,
what kind of person am I, you know?
Or what kind of person is this
other person kind of thing.
And if they're those maternal instinct
jewel for lack of a better way of putting
it person,
then what was it the first time
you feel like you should fire him,
you should fire him. You, you hang out
on that side of the spectrum. You got it.
Yeah.
How do you regain respect from your
employees after you've come across as too
nice?
My husband and I are business owners with
45 employees in a small software firm.
Since adding more employees in the last
18 months, the culture is changing.
I blame are easy going attitude.
Increasingly
there is an attitude problem
where negative push back
has become almost a daily
occurrence.
How do we lead our way out of this?
Okay, well this is a rough one. I'm not,
by no means I shouldn't have even said
it's a rough one. It's, it's a challenge,
right?
You have to hit the reset button for sure,
and you got to let people
know that things are changing.
Now I would straight up
have a meeting that you,
you sit everyone down and say,
hey, here's what's happening.
We are growing and as we grow we are going
to have to evolve just like a person.
As you get older, you have to evolve.
You have to become more mature,
and here's some of the things that we're
going to have to tighten up, right? Is
instead of, you know, everyone's just,
hey, if you come in and you want to go,
you got to, you know it's your
kid's birthday. Oh yeah, no
problem. Day Off, you say,
look,
that's not happening anymore.
We will do our best to let you
out for your daughter's birthday.
We will do our best to let you go.
Take care of family
members when they're sick.
We will do our best to give you bonuses
that you've become accustomed to.
We will do our best to
give you raises annually.
continue to take care of you,
but none of those things are guaranteed
at all.
We are trying to be profitable.
In fact,
we have to be profitable in order to
continue as a business on top of being
profitable. In order to grow, we
have to reinvest in the company.
We have to take the money that we make
and we have to put it back into this
company in order to grow
and we are going to grow.
That is our goal and in order to grow,
we are going to have to put procedures
and standards in place now that will
allow us to maintain some control
and efficiency as we grow.
If we don't do that,
we're going to fall apart.
So that is what we need to do.
Now why do we want to grow?
The reason we want to grow is
because we want to be bigger.
We want to create more opportunity
for everyone sitting in this room.
We're not trying to grow for us.
We're trying to grow for everyone.
The more opportunity everyone
has to advance in leadership
up to make more money.
That is what we're trying to do.
But we can only do that if we,
as we grow,
we evolve and become better and
become more efficient and become more
standardized in the next 18 to 24 months.
That is what we have to do as a company.
So I would have a meeting
and say something like that.
Something along those lines.
Lay down the law a little bit now also
then you have to change your attitude.
You have to somewhat change your
attitude because you are mister nice guy.
That's how you ended up in this position.
You know, the husband and wife team,
Mister, Mister and Missus, nice guy.
You can and should be nice as a leader.
I understand that.
But at this point the team
meets to get tightened up
and so you're going to have to
impose some discipline on them
in order for there to be freedom in
the future. Uh, surprisingly. Right.
But we know that now.
I had a friend who was a
platoon commander and he was,
he worked with me and I knew him.
And when he was a platoon commander,
he was a real nice guy, super nice
guy. When he was a platoon commander,
he was a nice guy,
super nice guy.
Things didn't work out good for him
because I don't know that, I don't,
I don't specifically know what happened,
but I know that things didn't go great.
And when he talked to me about it, because
the thing is, when I worked with them,
we were all bros and I was young enlisted
guy, but he, we know we all bros,
but we all had that level of
respect. Hey, you know what?
We can go out and have a beer tonight.
But tomorrow morning when we get to work,
I'm, I'm in the game
and I'm, you know, I'm,
I'm towing the line and that's pretty
much what we were all like all of us,
unless the guys working with this guy
and when he got to this new place,
new command, all of a sudden
it wasn't like that anymore.
And he was broing out with people
and when you get back into work,
they wanted to bro out at
work and it was like, well,
we don't need to listen to you.
We were having beers with you last night
and that's what he told me. He said,
you know,
I,
I was too nice of a guy and I didn't get
the respect that I needed to be able to
effectively run the platoon
and it was not good.
And he said something to me too,
which I guess I instinctively knew or
maybe I didn't, but it stuck with me.
You know,
it's real easy to give more slack to
someone when you have them on a tight
leash. Right. It's real easy. It's hard
to do. The other thing, it's hard to,
well,
listen to this,
when I have you on a tight leash and I
give you a little bit slack, you're happy.
You're like, oh look
at Jocko. He trusts me.
He's letting me go a little bit when I
give you all kinds of all kinds of slack
and all of a sudden I have to tighten
it up. I start pulling on the leash.
Well guess what? It chokes your neck.
It jokes. You start bringing in them.
And the further I got to pull you back
on Ian, the longer you're choking for.
And so by the time you get back to me,
you're ready to bite.
And so that's what you have to do.
You don't walk in and put the dogs out
and let them run wild on to the end of
the leash and let them run wherever they
want and then try and pull them back in.
Because when you let them go, by
the way, you're thinking yourself.
Well and you know this is a good dog.
And so when I let them run around and
he's not going to do anything wrong,
he's going to be a perfect same when
there's a chance that that's going to
happen. And there's a chance that that's
a good dog and you let them run around.
And when you say come back,
he comes back to you.
There's also a chance that he's not a
good dog. And when he gets out there,
he starts running and started biting.
People are running into the road
or doing whatever bad dogs do.
And so what?
What are you gonna have to do?
That dog is you've got to pull
them back to you and it's,
it's actually worse because we already
know this is a bad dog so that when you
pull him back,
he's pissed and he's going to bite you.
Whereas a good dog wasn't doing
anything bad the first place.
And when you pull them back in,
he looks at you and goes, Hey,
I must have gone to out of control.
I'm sorry I'm back in line now.
You see what I'm saying?
There's the,
the way the whole thing unfolds
is bad because the bad dog,
he's a bad dog and he's doing bad stuff.
When you give him slack on the
leash and when you pull them back,
he's going to snap at you, the good dog.
You give them all kinds of room on leash.
She's not doing anything good. And when
you pull them back, he goes, he goes, oh,
sorry, I didn't realize I was doing
something out of line master. Sure. I'll,
I'll keep it in check now. And you can
give me more slack if you want or not.
Doesn't matter. I want to be, I want
you to trust me. Meanwhile the bad dog,
he's just like Groundling is pissed.
So that's going to be a hard one.
I'm not, and like I said,
it's not impossible, but the
big thing you've got to do,
I think in this situation you gotta
be clear. Here's what's going on.
You could even potentially,
I don't know how well you are of
a speaker interacting with people.
You could even say something along
the lines of, you know, hey look,
we've been running this real loose
and I've been real, you know,
we've been doing everything we could to,
to run this as loose as possible,
but we got to tighten it up.
I think that's the,
I think you could say that cause
you don't want to say, look,
I've been being nice and I can't
be nice anymore that, that,
that comes across wrong. But to say, look,
we've been running in real loose here
and we've been trying to give you guys as
much freedom as we can and we still
want you guys to have freedom,
but we've got to put some
parameters in place that are gonna,
that are gonna allow us to run this bitch
business efficiently as we grow and as
we scale. You can quote
me on that one, but
yeah, makes sense. When you see him be
clear and consistent, you know, like,
oh, um, you know,
some people they'll implement rules and
I'm speaking from an employee standpoint
where I'm looking at the boss when they're
trying to put in new rules to tighten
it up so to speak. Cause in the night
club industry that tends to happen,
you know, managers broing out with,
I like to term bro out, by the way.
You never heard that if you never
heard that before? I don't think so.
Not that I can remember,
but it's interesting.
I thought that was
pretty common vernacular,
especially amongst a bro like yourself,
bro out broken out with them. Um, yeah.
And the nightclub managers tend to
bro out with people or you know,
bro out with girls or whatever,
the waitresses, whatever, whatever.
I don't know if you
can bro out with girls.
I know that's all I have to go over it.
Probably a different word for it,
a group of words, whatever.
Um, but nonetheless, that
tends to happen. So, you know,
some that sense, same situation, you know,
you get nightclubs in disarray
as a business, you know,
then they got to tighten it up and apply
more rules and now you got to, you know,
whatever with the clock ins,
it's like just a little rules
and negative attitude though.
All these rallies, these damn
rules. Yeah, Bro, I'm a late person.
So the whole clock in thing. Anyway,
long story, but I'm so anti echoes.
So when the manager would
implement the rules,
but they don't follow the
rules, you know, it's men. It,
they just won't take
and people get more mad.
But when you see there was this man
and he died too. Unfortunately. Joel,
he was, um, he was, he was our
boss for, for awhile and he, uh,
he had to kind of do that,
like implement new rules,
but this was the guy he would bro
out with you. But like it was weird,
he did this weird kind of balance where
he would break some rules but then he'd
follow rules.
But the rules that he broke,
he wouldn't care if you broke them
kind of thing. These are all small,
teeny tiny goals by the way. Um, but he
was a real consistent person, you know,
where if he wanted something done, we were
all doing it, including him, you know.
And I remember thinking, man, this,
I really liked this guy in that way as
well where he's telling us to do stuff,
but he won't like, cause there's other
managers at all, man, I can go into it.
And then where there's other
managers and they were straight up.
Like I'm the manager here. It just
needs to be nimble and worships me.
And it's a weird dynamic
in nightclubs anyway.
And they wouldn't follow the rules at all,
you know,
but you had to cause you're the employee,
you know, kind of thing. But yeah,
when you're a manager,
and again from an employee standpoint and,
and I see my boss following
the new rules consistently.
Yeah. It's so much easier to sign
on and it's Kinda like, okay,
that's what we're doing.
I dig it. And yeah,
if you combine it with like what you
said, being clear, well I'm down,
I'm down for the change. I get it,
man. I get it. Oh yeah. Next question.
Jocko.
No bad teams,
only bad leaders and always the
same relationship with each boss.
Yet you also staged a mutiny.
How do you reconcile that? Okay,
so what he's talking about,
obviously no bad teams,
no bad
leaders is from extreme ownership.
And it's actually from before
that Napoleon said the same thing.
Hackworth said the same thing.
We changed the words a little bit.
But so that's, and then the other thing
he's talking about is that I always say,
or I have the same relationship
with every boss I've ever had,
whether they were stupid or smart or
whether they were aggressive or passive,
whether they were big ego or humble.
I always had the same relationship
with all of them. That is,
they trusted me and they gave me
what I need you to do my job. So
how do I reconcile the then,
then he's talking about stage to mutiny
because we had a kind of a mutiny in one
of my platoons,
conductor when I was a young enlisted guy.
And so how can you do that?
Right?
If I had all these great relationships
with all my bosses, but I staged a mutiny.
Interestingly,
I actually had a decent relationship
with a guy that I staged a mutiny with.
Now that I think about it.
So to go back to the earlier question,
what I'm talking about being a renegade
and you know, being a rebel and,
and like I said, you, you have to
rebel when it is necessary. So,
and also for the mutiny that is in
question. I need to make it clear here.
I didn't stage the mutiny,
it wasn't me.
It was kind of a group effort that was
somewhat led by the leadership of our,
the enlisted leadership of our platoon.
And it was a movement that I certainly
supported and was on board with and we
were kind of the e five mafia
in that platoon. Sure. Yeah.
So we were kind of had the voice of the
people write me in a certain group of
guys actually from my buds class who are,
we're all kind of yeah.
Kind of just fired up about things.
And uh, you know, I,
it wasn't like,
the thing is,
it wasn't like the platoon commander
had a couple of weaknesses. Right.
And maybe he wasn't the best of tactics
or maybe it wasn't that, you know,
he wasn't the best shot or anything
like wasn't the best athlete. No,
he was a good athlete. He
tactically, he was like marginal.
Um, but what, he didn't have talk
about this all the time. What,
he didn't have his,
he didn't have any humility at all.
And so he wasn't listening to anyone
that was giving him any input,
including he had very experienced
senior enlisted advisors.
So the platoon chief and the
platoon Lpo were awesome guys,
very respected seals.
One of them had been in the first Gulf
War on the ground getting after it as
much as he could.
So these guys were experienced
on the senior chief was a
really, really smart guy
and this guy wasn't listening to.
And so you had somebody
in the situation was,
they would have been bad for the platoon
to have this type of leader in there.
And now think about this,
if it's bad for the platoon,
that it's bad for your mission.
Okay?
If you don't have a good platoon,
you can't execute mission well.
And that's the bottom line to this
question. That is how I reconcile this.
How does this situation affect the mission
affect our ability to accomplish the
mission?
How does it do it?
If we have a bad leader and
it makes us a bad platoon,
then we're not going to be
able to accomplish our mission.
And therefore I need to
help get rid of this person.
Because my number one thing that I'm
trying to do is be good at my mission.
Hmm.
And obviously a more unified team is
going to accomplish the mission more
effectively and more
efficiently, period. So
that you know what?
That is why it is so important for people
to understand the mission and the goal
and the commander's intent.
Because all we've, your decisions
are based on and guided by that
understanding of understanding of what the
mission is.
Hmm.
So you need to put the mission first
all the time to make the right decision.
Now, as soon as I say that, what
pops into your head? Oh, Jocko,
you care about the mission more than
you care about your men. Not True.
Because think about this.
If you are executing
your mission effectively,
you are taking care of your men.
That's in the business world and it's in
the battlefield because in the business
world, if I'm executing my, my mission
effectively, guess what we're doing?
We're making more money, be more
profitable, we're gaining more clients,
we're growing and therefore I'm taking
care of my employees because I'm keeping
them employed and making them more
bonuses and making them more money and,
and offering them more leadership
opportunities in combat. Same thing.
If we are good and I execute my
mission effectively, guess what?
We've mitigated risk. The, the,
the in the best possible way.
The more we mitigate risk,
the more people are alive,
the blessed casualties we take.
So if I'm doing everything
geared towards the mission,
then then I am taking care of my men.
Cause by the way,
if I'm running a mission with heavy
casualties, what about my next mission?
Right?
So if you're my boss and you tell me
to charge this machine gun nest with my
guys and I say, boss, you know we
shouldn't do that right now. You, you,
you carry out the mission. Okay, well
who's going to do the next mission? Right?
There's not unlimited guys here,
so you can't do it.
You can't run a mission after you've taken
heavy casualties. Just like you can't.
If you as a businessperson,
if you expend all of your
capital on one project,
well guess what? You can't do
the next project. So good job.
You accomplish the one mission,
but you can't accomplish anymore on the,
if you incur a bunch of casualties for
one mission, you can't accomplish anymore.
So in both those cases,
the more effectively you,
you handle the mission, not just the
one mission, but your broad mission,
your strategic mission,
the better you do that,
the better you are taking care of your
men and the better you are taking care of
your people in the business world.
So
and on top of that,
yeah,
on top of that,
99% of the time your mission is aligned
with the best thing for your people.
That's what I'm saying, 99% of the time,
if we make more money as a company,
it helps all my people.
If we,
if we accomplish missions in the most
effective and efficient and take the lease
casualties, that's the best
thing for my people. So,
okay,
back to the question,
how do I reconcile these things?
I look at how I can best accomplish the
mission and if at best accomplish the
mission to rebel against what's happening.
There's some cases where I might not,
you might be my boss and
I might not like you,
but you've got a great relationship with
the army commander and we're working in
their battle space.
Hmm.
Would it make sense for me to throw
a mutiny and get you fired? No.
It would make no sense whatsoever.
It's going to be better for our mission.
If I say echo socks,
but I'm going to listen to them and we're
going to massage this thing and would
make things work because he has such
a good relationship with this army
commander that he,
he's making things happen.
Hmm.
So I might not do it.
I might not stage emit a mutiny.
Not based on the fact that you,
that your level of sucking but based on
the fact that what's more important to
me is that we accomplish our mission
and if you have a good relationship with
the army commander, I'm going
to keep you around. If you were,
if you were in a business
situation and you had,
you were not doing a good job and
you're one of my subordinates,
you're not doing a good job,
but you have these great relationships
with all these clients and we're
accomplishing our mission well because
you've built these great relationships.
Am I just going to fire you
because I think you're doing a fix.
I think you're a crappy leader of
your men. No, actually I'm not.
What is best for the mission now I might
have to secondary and tertiary plans to
move you into position where you don't
have to handle the operational things
that you suck at.
And I might put you in a position where
you've just going to become, you know,
a business debt,
a Biz Dev guy where you're out there
meeting and greeting people cause that's
what you're good at.
I might make that happen,
but I'm not just going to go
echo was a bad leader. Fire Him.
Throw away the the skill that you do have.
And now we're not accomplishing our
mission or cause I ruined all the
relationships.
Cause now you go to all these,
all these other partners that we have and
you're going to, yeah, Jocko fired me.
He's pathetic. He goes, it
realize what we're doing here.
I'm going over to this company.
Come with me.
Bring Your Business over here with me.
So you reconcile it by
looking at the mission.
And the mission is almost always aligned
with taking care of your people and
taking care of your people in the sense of
imposing discipline or not imposing
discipline is being disciplined and making
them work and giving them,
training them hard, pushing them.
That is generally what taking care of
your people is taking care of your people.
Is it? Hey, you know what?
Echo, ah, you know, uh,
don't worry about that video that
you owe to the client. I know you,
I know what your daughter's birthday.
You go ahead and go home for the day.
Am I taking care of you? If I do that,
they'll say, am I taking care of you? No,
I'm not. I'm actually hurting you
because now we got a bad reputation.
We delivered the video late.
The company passes word to the
next company. It says, Hey,
you know those guys are there.
Video is okay,
but it doesn't matter because it was late.
Hmm.
Now that's the reputation we have now.
Fast forward six months, we're downsizing.
I don't need you anymore. I'm
going to make the, you know,
I don't need for video makers,
I only need one and you're not the one.
You see what I'm saying?
So I'm not taking care of my people.
If I focus on the mission, which
is, hey, echo, I apologize.
I know what your daughter's birthday,
but guess what? We owe this video.
We got to get it done and you got
to get in here and make it happen.
Am I taking care of you then? Yes, I am.
I know it doesn't feel that way, but yes,
I am.
Yeah. Yeah. I did.
Making sure they're equipped,
capable and
treated fairly. Yeah. Yeah.
I said impose discipline on them.
Yeah. And like that doesn't work.
Yeah.
But what you have to do is
you have to impose this point.
There's the dichotomy. Yeah.
Cause you don't want to say echo.
You will come in and make this video.
I'm imposing Sonia. I'd be like, Echo,
we owe this video.
We said we're going to turn it in and
let me tell you the ramifications if we
don't do this. Here's what's going to
hurt. It's going to hurt this, this, this,
this,
and this.
Going to eventually could end up with
you not having a job and me not having a
business. Yeah. Do you like the
sounds of that? No. You don't.
No.
You might be the wrong guy to ask about
this and maybe you're not. I don't know.
But what do you think?
So you mentioned missing your daughter.
My daughter's birthday. I didn't miss
my daughter's birthday by the way. Um,
did you say you did or did not? Did Not,
but my son just had a first birthday.
I did miss that,
but it's his first birthday cakes.
So I've always thought this was before
I had any kids with any birthdays that
the first birthday, that's where the
parents and stuff for the king, you know,
he doesn't remember the first
year, his first birthday. He never,
no, I'm definitely going to be
the wrong person. No, keep going.
Oh boy.
So missing birthdays,
is that like a bell curve? Like
okay, one first birthday, age one,
you king sort of miss that age zero.
You can't really miss that. Yeah.
Meaning when they're born, go go, go talk
to the military people in there. I know,
I know, I know. Yeah, no, you're right.
And I'm saying if you have
the options and you know,
we're speaking in terms of okay,
if you're, I mean you sort
of have a, like in terms of,
you know, we're that this company, you're
my boss on the video maker. Hey Echo,
you know, we've got to get this video
done. Whatever. I don't know. That may,
maybe even in an extreme case,
but I'm saying in a general sense,
which birthdays are more expendable,
that's ultimately the question.
And it doesn't necessarily mean in this
specific, I'm gonna tell you right now,
as a guy that was in the military for
20 years, the birthday, if you're there,
it's a luxury. If you're there
for Christmas, it's a luxury.
If you're there for thanksgiving,
it's a luxury.
I missed all kinds of that stuff all
over the place. Just like a big Joe,
you big, you know, you're just
not going to be there. Okay.
So now we're not in the military.
No. And it's less about
missing him or not. Okay.
So at the end of the day, no matter
what birthday, even right now,
you're thinking if you miss
them, no. Huge deal. No,
I mean if I actually
thought it was a huge deal,
I would have to choose an entirely
different lifestyle and life. Right,
right. And I'll tell you what,
my kids, no. Yeah, yeah. Okay.
They've always known.
Well, okay, so guess what?
Someone's out there getting
after his name, his name to
my dad. No, no, no. Okay.
Okay. He missed another
birthday. Don't care. I get you
yet. No, you're, I dig it and,
but that's kind of in a way, I mean,
not to be too specific and split hairs,
but I'm going to do it anyway.
I mean,
not even necessarily you
and your specific situation.
The most important for exactly around
the spectrum of ages five through 11 five
through 11 are have the most weight,
most weight. Okay, so not zero,
not when they're born. Nope. So if you,
if you miss the birth of your
child because you had to work.
And I'm not saying military,
I'm saying because you were trying
to finish some report or something or
whatever or you're trying
to be there. Okay. So,
but comparatively speaking,
the,
the birth of your child
compared to the fifth birthday,
you say fifth birthday is more important
because they don't remember anything
from zero to four. It's just a big
blue. Dang. That's a good point. And
it's just nothing happening.
All,
it sounds like those parents that you're
taking your kids, and I did this too.
I actually, I didn't, I did it
with my first kids. My wife's like,
we're going to go to take the girls
to Disneyland and that's it. Oh, okay.
Walking around at Disneyland, which is
pretty close to a living hell to pay.
Actually standing in lines
in the Anaheim summertime,
like just baking and yet here's the deal.
The girls are just so excited the
whole time and so happy and me.
No. So now I don't, I haven't been to
any of those things in a long time.
Um,
actually I went with a business
group and walked around Disneyland,
Disney world and I was
like, you've gotta a killer
now, but this is the thing.
The kids don't remember it. You can
show them pictures and they go, oh,
that's cool. You can stage those
pictures like oh nine landings.
Like just set them up and be
like, oh yeah, Cinderella,
whatever. We seem to be four or five.
Yeah, five years. Okay. Actually men.
That's a good point
because when I say now,
I'm sure there's developmental things
happening. When there, when you do things,
when you participate in
activities with your kids,
obviously zero to five but you know,
you could probably,
it probably be more developmentally
helpful for you to spend a day with them,
you know,
coaching them and in Jujitsu or coaching
them and boxing or coaching them and
Moitai or coaching them and shooting
or coaching them in archery or coaching
them and go hunting small animals or
coaching them in how to do combat trauma
care. Just like general failure four year
old. Yeah, you're right. You're right. Um,
yeah, yeah. That's as opposed to hey,
you're going to Disneyland. Look at, yeah,
that's another good question is like the
birthday thing. So, so, so cause the only,
cause you mentioned because by 11 they
don't care anymore. By 11 they don't care.
Oh well my kids were, were all like,
oh my birthday, don't care. Yeah.
So man, that's a good place. We have
a rule. You get to pick your word,
you go out for dinner
on your birthday night.
And in the last like five birthdays,
we haven't even been able to
pull that off successfully. Yeah.
So obviously it's going to be what,
what the group is used to.
But as far as the kid in you
missing the birthday for, you know,
for the cow was a kid.
You know what I used to pick,
cause I that used to be in my family too.
We get to like pick dinner.
You notice to pick. Yeah. Chicken
patties. Chicken for dinner. Oh,
just from the floor store.
Just get some chicken patties.
I used to love those things. Dang. Yeah.
I remember in school I went
to Koloa elementary school.
I used to love the chicken patties.
They're, yeah, they're dope.
The chicken patties or you sound like
chicken mcnugget local. Big Flat Chicken.
Mcnuggets yeah. And I didn't even like,
I didn't like steak until I was in the,
because,
because we didn't have a lot of state
grown up because steak is expensive. Yeah.
You know what I mean? Yeah. Especially
that Ribeye. Yeah. Especially that Revi.
So we didn't have steak, we had chicken
patties tasted good to me. Pretty Dope.
And sometimes you know what else?
Of course you want Mcdonald's when
you're seven. Sure anyone's codes.
Get some fries and a shamrock shake shack.
I had told, cause you know I
love mint chocolate chip, right?
So I had told all my kids about the,
the original mint chocolate chip milkshake
was the shamrock shake it Mcdonald's
back in a dairy, which they'd
have around Saint Patty's day,
which by the way isn't around my birthday,
but it just made, came to my mind. So,
so when I was a kid,
we had shamrock shakes.
Saint Patty's Day, they're mint
shakes. And when I was a kid,
they were amazing and I was so,
and I hadn't had one in 30 years,
maybe more, maybe 40 years,
hadn't had a shamrock shake. And I saw a
little advertisement. I said, all kids,
guess what?
These are like mint chocolate chip
milkshakes,
but there's no chocolate chips.
So it's just smooth mint ice
cream milkshake from Mcdonald's.
Yup. Can I sent my daughter
out to go get us all?
Go get us all shamrock shakes brought
him home. They worked disgusting.
They were nothing like what they
used to be. Yeah. So Mcdonald's,
I gave you a shot. Sorry about that.
I'm surprised he gave him a shot.
I am too,
but it's been 40 something years beats
since I had a shamrock shake and I
remembered him, so I figured we'll go
with it. Maybe there was gusting gather,
probably go. Not even my kids liked him.
Not even my eight year old Dang, who just,
you know, is an eight year old
that just looks at things and say,
that's ice cream. I'm on it. She didn't
even like it. None of them. No one.
They were discussing, we threw them
all away. Don't waste your money. Yeah,
don't waste your money. Yeah. Don't
waste your money on Mcdonald's.
That's my personal recommendation period.
Shamrock shake or other otherwise, yeah,
yeah, yeah. It's not help not
help. Not Helping you in any way.
Did you know that they just,
I mean this is gonna sound obvious
now that I'm saying it out loud.
They add the green coloring to it,
to the ice cream. Make it green.
Well, yeah, when you get briars
it's white. Yeah. I got here,
I've talking to him one, I mean my wife
and whatever family, the family goes to a,
or the Oregon coast. That's
where the Tillamook cheese
factory. Wait chief. Yeah.
Tillamook cheese.
The actual big factory.
And you can go on little tours and they
give you ice cream. I'm like, okay,
I want that mint mint chip of course.
And they give it to me and they
hand it to math and I'm like,
the first time I see it, I was
like, Hey, that's not mine.
That's obviously just the
regular chocolate over here.
And I for real said that. I was like, oh,
I ordered the mint. And he goes, Oh yeah,
that's meant. And then it all
kind of came to me like, Oh yeah,
I'm pretty dumb for if you get briars.
Briers is white,
which is the preferred brand, to be quite
honest with you. Is it okay. All right.
Well, at least at least the
ones that I've tried. Yeah. So,
so back to the birthday thing,
if you miss the birth of your child,
technically you're right.
Technically for the question,
because I'm talking about like how upset
or how much is it going to mean not
affected at all at all really.
But here's the thing,
if it like as a cohesive family, that
might be a thing. If you have the option,
I'm saying if you're overseas, come, come
on man, let's face it. That's a legit,
but if you have the choice,
so you miss the birth of your child,
that's more of like a family thing.
Like, okay, but that's not what,
that's not the question because
it's always the first birthday,
the first year birthday. That's kind
of a, it's for the adults. Yeah.
It's for the other people. Second,
third, fourth, and fifth. The fourth.
And in my experience, maybe they're
in the game a little bit. Yeah. Yeah.
It depends on the kid who's conditioned
them that they don't expect anything
good. Yeah, I guess, yeah.
Life Sucks, man. Life sucks.
Nothing special about your stupid
birthday. Everybody loses a bunch of,
you were born on that day.
A bunch of people born tomorrow.
A bunch of people born yesterday.
Get over yourself, kid. Concur,
four years old. I know. Bunch
of people who turn four anyway.
Uh, agree. I think that
age two all the way to
21 that's my opinion. Those are the ones
that if they want you there, ew, ew,
ew. I don't make cars going to
watch around at her 21st birthday.
She better otherwise. Cabo
going to say that. Right?
She's not a lot in comp. Cabo, Shinola,
check. We're going to be way more.
Yeah,
more Jocko.
What do you think about when you
don't feel like getting after it?
You know,
I put this out the other day and
I think it's important.
All right,
so Rome wasn't built in a day.
We all know that.
Everyone hears that,
but Rome also didn't fall
apart overnight either.
It took hundreds of years
for Rome to reach its peak,
but it also took time,
hundreds of years for Rome
to decay and fall apart,
and that is representative of life
because you don't achieve worthwhile goals
quickly or easily.
They take time,
they take struggle,
they take relentless
pursuit day in and day out.
That's what it takes.
Okay.
But also things don't usually
fall apart quickly either.
At least at first it,
it's, it's a slow process.
A little slip here,
little set back over there,
a little wearing down of
discipline and will over time.
That's the thing.
Success and failure are
generally slow processes
either slowly building things up
or gradually tearing them down.
And that's why I say you've
got to pay attention.
You have to watch,
you have to watch every single second.
Okay.
Because those seconds
they turn into minutes and minutes turn
into hours and hours turned into days
and days turn in two years.
Yeah.
Hints.
So that second,
that second that just went by.
That counted.
Thanks. So did that second
and so did that one and Ian,
those precious seconds,
you are either building
or you were decaying.
You are either gaining ground.
Yeah.
Or You were losing ground
in that second
and in every second,
every second counts.
So make every second
count.
And I think
that's all I've got for tonight.
So Echo,
if people want to make it
count for this podcast,
maybe you could
tell them how they can go ahead
and do that if they want to.
Sure.
Be Happy to actually,
when we're talking about origin,
why did Pete choose origin as
thinning? He told the story, right?
That must be slacking on
the listening on though.
Nonetheless it makes sense
because the origin of all these,
all the gear is here in
the u s just happens to be.
But that's a big thing.
The origin.
So what do we make gies out of say cotton,
you know? Okay, well we'll
just take the cotton,
grow the cotton in the u s what
do they do with the cotton?
Turn it into they do. Yeah.
Yes. Stuff. Diet. Yeah.
Turn it into a fabric.
Oh yeah,
yeah. And they do all of that. They
don't import it, you know, from wherever.
You know, some undisclosed
American Hailey's. Yeah. Anyway,
so maybe that's why it's called origin.
Cause the origin is a significant thing.
Right. Anyway. All right, cool.
So origin, what is origin?
Origin is the best gear
in the world. Straight up.
Objectively, not subjectively.
Objectively.
I
got proof bump,
so I got to Ge.
We went to this origin immersion
camp for Jujitsu origin,
Jujitsu immersion camp.
Nope. Good Fun. By the way,
that was your first time in the origin
g wasn't it? Yes, I think. Yeah.
Yeah. I saw you with
yours. It was cool. Um,
yeah, so cool camp. Got The g, um,
then I come home, got to, by the way,
actually I got to keep
tops one pair of pants. Um,
come home, made me want to train more
in the gay. By the way, I thought,
I don't know if it was the
gay or the camp. We're both
probably both. Yeah. Anyway,
so this whole week I changed and every
single time I went in someone mentioned
the Ge and it's not like it's pink or
something like that. When they're like,
hey CFO, put on his g, yeah, it's
normal. You can get the blue. I had the,
I have the white one and everyone
is like, oh, what's that?
Jeff Glover was one of them. And this
is the person who's like, you know,
if he says that it's something,
it's not like some, you know,
fashion person has had don't like that
logo or that's a cool, you know, anyway,
it was someone who knows. Anyway,
everyone asking like what up with his ski.
So I go into the spiel made here.
I might have lost somebody cause
they took real long saying it.
But nonetheless it's dope.
And then another one was Jeff Higgs.
We know who that is. [inaudible] do
you know who that is? I sure do. Yeah.
The person that Joppa talks about,
when he first started to
get introduced to Jujitsu,
the guy who reintroduced to Jujitsu,
he and I got introduced to Jujitsu
together and then he went out and trained
hard. Yeah, I think it was the day he
got his purple belt has purple house,
the White,
I mean we trained with master chief Bailey
overseas that for like three months.
And then we came back.
We are in different platoons,
but he started training for
real with Fabio Santos. Yeah.
And the day he got his purple belt,
I'm pretty sure it was
the day you got us for,
well he came to my house and was like,
let's go train. And I said all yeah,
so think about purple belt versus
white belt and he, you know,
triangle arm lock,
everything rear naked choke and it's
Kinda tall. Too Tall. He's tall,
strong,
putting beat down bone.
You boney like in terms of when
he's impacting you with his elbows.
Yeah. Real bony. He's hitting me.
He's got the bones cutting. Yeah.
He's like this triangle feels like it's
going to cut your head off cause he's
bony. Yeah. He knows some
good judo too, Huh? Yeah,
yeah, yeah. And he's got a
real, he's got a real, um,
he's always in touch with the whole
idea of using this to effectively defend
yourself in a street and scenario.
He's always in touch with that.
He always adds in a little,
and if you're in the
street you could do, there's
four idea. He did that.
I went up to studio five 40.
Yeah. Oh, oh for Berry Street.
I had to train at 10:00 AM I had some
stuff to do and then they were only doing
no gay at the VI suckled studio five
40 he exists teaching the class.
Rob's Apps, he's the owner or
whatever. Even he mentioned
the Ge, he was like, well,
he's like, what gives is this? Yeah.
Cause it's a different material
specially not only specially made,
especially woven, specially designed for
Jujitsu. Yeah. So yeah. And I was like,
Oh yeah, that's that origin
stuff. Don't worry about that.
And he's like, oh I like,
I think I might have one. You know,
he's the kind of with like 1000 sec,
I think I have one of these or whatever.
And I was like,
you don't have this one bro. And I
just kept walking, you know. Anyway,
then afterwards it was afterwards when
Higgs was like, he's like, this is the,
I think he even said this
is the most interesting gay.
And he was like rubbing it in his fingers,
you know, when he grabbed my sleep,
if this is the most interesting guy
I've ever seen, something like that.
You know when that's the
axiom guerrilla we've,
yeah, cause they have a normal per wave,
which looks like the little tiny purse.
Sure.
American parole.
But the axiom that gorilla weave is,
or is it the Dragon? We've, they both
look very similar. Yeah. But they're both,
we've, oh yeah. One of them
looks like, um, like it's like,
I'm not going to say velvet, I'm not
going to do that. But it looks like that,
you know. No, it looks like
diamonds. Which one was the one,
remember we were looking at, um, and uh,
we were looking and they were saying like,
like I was like, Dang, this looks super
luxurious. That's not the one I have.
By the way. He was like this up. The other
one, I don't know which one was which.
But nonetheless, people seem to like
the geeks and the pants are dope.
It has the, it's like you
can choose drawstring, but it
has the, um, like, you know,
like surf shorts where they have the
velcro Boehm and it's like fitted.
They go and sizes like of your
waste. It's not just like er, uh,
which actually I'm not against
the whole a one 82 83, you know,
I'm not against that. It's actually,
it's fine. It's cool. Super simple. Um,
but this is good. It's like when you get
it, you can order yours, pant size, boom.
But you know, when you put it on it's
going to be dope anyway. And it is dope.
And you know,
the public responded in that way as well.
So also rash guards, tee shirts. Yeah.
We're gonna make a bunch of other stuff.
Yeah, there's some cool stuff on
there and the point is really sure.
I'm talking about the guy because I was
all up in that gee this week and that's
fresh on my mind and it's one of
those things that sticks in there. Um,
also at the camp, um, you know how
like when you give your laundry,
I only had one. So you give your
laundry, you, you're out of Ge,
you can't go to the next session unless
you get another Gig, which is kind of,
I wasn't really about that,
but so I would use them twice in a
row and they dry surprisingly fast.
It's not going to surprise.
They drive fast.
They're not a hundred
percent cotton and polyester.
I think in there with silver coated,
they non-AHC Kenny.
It's antimicrobial. Silver coating on it.
Not like silver. You can see it. Yeah.
But yeah,
that's why that's the thing,
that's the same thing with
mine when I pulled mine out,
when I pull mine out of the washing
machine after the spin cycle,
it's almost dry. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Like a
pair of surf shorts basically. But Dang,
it feels comfortable. It's nice.
Yeah. So yeah, man. Anyway, so yeah,
or origin main, like the State
Maine, not m. I. N I mean I and eat.
So origin main.com go on there. There's
a lot of cool stuff on there, man.
A lot of it. Oh yeah. Check that one
out. That's the best gear in America.
All made in America.
Best gear in the world.
All made America also
Jaquis some supplements. So
still on origin main.com right.
There's a part and I was,
cause I was looking for him.
You go on the top and it's his labs.
You Click on there, boom. That's
where all the supplements.
Super Krill cause normal meal.
You mean Jocko Supercrown soccer.
Super Cruel. He couldn't just do the Krill
Oil Honda. You couldn't no, no, no, no.
That's super girl. Super Cool. Like, like
it Krill when you can get Super Krill,
one of those deals. Super close.
Got The capes on. All right,
cool. There you go. And you know, um,
joint warfare, which is, you know,
a blend of joint.
Yeah.
Furbished is Furby shingle
word for refurbishing. Right.
But the refurbishing is just doing it
again or, yeah, for sure. For a machine.
And that's got the things
that I always take.
Curcumin [inaudible] and the [inaudible]
is in the form of sea cucumber suite.
That's where it comes from
me. So yeah. Well, the legit,
the ancient not interesting,
I guess you could call it layers is
this is exactly what you were taking for
years and you were like gay guests.
What origin in the house?
Let's just make that, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Well sometimes I'd have to combine
different things before. Yeah.
But now I don't have to combine anything
anymore. They're already combined joint.
We're going to combine it into one deal.
Yeah.
It's warfare.
Joint warfare against doing
against joint weakness. Yup.
It's a good idea too, by the way,
because now I've got two kids.
I remember when I told the story like,
you know when you wake up and my daughter,
she told that story. Yeah.
I'm going to tell it again.
So she's the jump on my back
when I, when you, right,
when you wake up that's your least warm.
That's when you're trying
to warm up and get,
do physical stuff that least warm you'll
ever be just in everyday life is when
you wake up.
Yeah.
Those first 12 burpees or are hard one
hour before you do the burpees that
moment. So this is the exact
moment when my daughter, you know,
40 pounds or so jumped on my back, my
shoulders, my back, where my shoulders,
whatever she chose. And you know, after I
took Krill for, I think it was like five,
six days, boom. I could easily do it.
I didn't have to like focus on my form,
nothing like that.
Now I've got two kids and my
daughter who's older is heavier.
So not this morning,
yesterday morning I go to wait
grill up for school or whatever.
I already have my son, he weighs, I don't
know how much she weighs, but he's one,
I have him, she still wants to jump on my
shoulder. I have him cause he's like, oh.
And then he sees her jumping asleep shit.
So basically I'm the,
what do you call it, the vehicle that
they're writing on early in the morning,
by the way. Still no problem.
Still going strong. So yeah, man,
that's it. That's a joint warfare
situation right there and Krill supercrew.
Get on it.
You'll be glad you did.
Also checkout on it.com/jocko this
is where I get my kettle bells.
Then I meant, I mentioned this, I
got the gorilla ones, 72 pounds.
So I'm cruising right,
not lifting,
cruising and jade comes, my brother
comes in. I was like, I was like, yeah,
go check out this new kettle bells
I got. And it goes, it's all, Yay.
Those are cool. I was like,
go ahead, pick them up.
He goes and make that kind of heavy, you
know? But I've been doing kettle bells,
so I was like, Nah, let me show you
what not even warmed up. Nothing.
Speaking of Krill oil.
Yeah.
It was actually really the Krill
oil springing into action. Really.
Boom. I do it. And um, you know,
had to show him what up nonetheless
that was done with those kettlebells,
which are dealt by the way.
Um,
I'm not gonna say get the designer ones.
I'm not gonna say that.
I think you should,
but I'm not going to say to do that.
I say go on there on
it.com/jocko check it out.
You like something,
get something.
They got cool battle ropes in any kind
of exercise. Stuff like the new stuff,
functional training equipment.
Keep your workout interesting.
If you care about your workout
to being interesting, unlike
Jocko Jocko, do they care
about that stuff? Um,
don't get addicted to the
interesting information like I did.
I think I'm past that addiction now. But
um, you know, you do run that risk on it.
Dotcom. Slash. Chocolate,
that's a good one. Also,
good way to support is when you're
buying these books that Jocko reviews.
We didn't review one today but you know,
in the future Jocko might
and has in the past. Um, I,
we organize these books by episode on
Jocko podcast.com and on the top click on
books from podcasts. Boom. All in order
to support the podcast. Click
through there to get them. Boom,
it takes you to Amazon supports
the podcast that way. Also,
if you're doing any other
shopping, hey, feel free.
If you're going to buy a new video
camera in the event of your video camera
braking on the plane, when you check your
luggage and the video camera's in Ne,
you want to get another one? Boom.
Get it through there. All good big,
uh, big support on that one. What?
It seems like an opportune time to
talk about your other video camera.
Sure. Oh yeah. Yeah.
Or maybe not actually,
it's a good story though.
It's not like a tragic story,
which it kind of felt like when
you mentioned it, I was like, oh,
it brought me back. Okay.
So here's the story.
We go to Maine, right? Technically we
go to Boston, then drive to me. Yup.
Right. So, you know, dude, too drunk to
drive to you when we rent a car. Well,
the car rental place and I have three
bags. Will you have what? One, two, yeah.
Two bags. Vessel, five bags. Total
cuter bag and my suitcase. Yeah,
so five bags total.
I have a big bag with equipment in it,
suitcase with, you know, did you just
see stuff and clothes and whatnot.
And then the third bag, which was the
carry on bit pretty big, you know,
most important was important.
Has a um,
it has an important camera
in there that I use. My,
my favorite camera I've ever
had really good camera. Uh,
has some value to it will say.
And it's a red camera. Yeah, it's
epic. W technically it's,
it's an awesome camera.
Is it the best you can buy or is there
one more? It depends on what you mean,
but best. But it's, yeah, there's one sort
of level. Okay. Well I'll tell you this,
it ain't cheap. No, it ain't cheap at all.
In some places in the country you could
buy a house for the cost of this camera.
Yeah. So it's an expensive camera.
Yeah. And, and you'd think like, okay,
echo is going to take really good care
of this stuff, which I do. Really,
that's what I carry it
on. Boom, boom. You know,
doesn't even trust anyone touching it.
Cause going to carry it with them. Yeah.
Okay. Continue. So boom, we
hit in the rental car, we
got apparently got five bags,
still count for a was there, there was
no, there was some kind of confusion.
You know what happened? Yes,
there was. Yes. Remember,
because remember when you were getting in,
what was it,
like an expedition or something like that.
And now those new ones have that automatic
tail door that goes up and you know
what it was,
I think there's like a sensor under the
bumper that if you like put your foot
under there, it closes. Like if you know,
like a hands free closing
the door situation.
So the thing started closing all
the main Dako yeah. And the girl,
the rental girl was trying to save
me. Yeah. And she couldn't. Yeah.
So he always like be strong for her,
which was kind of funny
cause I didn't even care,
but I just kind of like put
my back into it and stopped.
But I was watching her kind of chuckling
because she's trying to stop it and it
wasn't stopping. It was, she was looking,
she had a look on her face
like I was about to die.
She tried to work up like Indiana Jones.
I was going to get my head cut off by the
door slamming shut and I was just kind
of like laughing at the whole situation.
But that caused some confusion.
Apparently it was like your mind,
it was like a little micro emergency
that happened and so I was like boom,
flustered but wait what all the bags
are in or not and we're trying to fit.
Remember cause we were trying
to get the seats down the way.
There's like maybe three quads I
major things going on now and you know
for the sake story I'm just going to
continue. So bull, we get it all, all,
we get it all loaded and at one point
like we're like halfway up there's a three
hour drive and by the way if
we don't stop and we did stop.
So it was like five hours
or something like that.
So we stopped and I remember his
daughter got fried chicken by the way.
It was good
and I was stoked nonetheless.
I had a thought and it was literally
lasted three seconds. Like,
I don't really remember putting my
camera bag in the car, but what am,
I do not put it in the car. It's like
the most important back. So whatever.
So we just continue,
we get up there and right as we pull
into like park tied seconds later,
we're in the back country of Maine.
Yeah.
Like not even knowing first
time there by the way,
which I dunno what that even means,
but either way we're there and
I'm all pumped up cause my rib,
I was stoked to go in and see everybody
and hang out. Yeah. You can see everyone.
Everyone's inside the light of the gym so
they can't see that were outside. Yeah.
So I'm all but I'm stoked. So it's, yeah,
the beginning of the deal can
finisher if you will. And um,
right as we kind of rolled to a stop,
I'm thinking, man, did I, you know,
he kind of account we're here and
now you start to account for it.
And I don't remember that stuff.
So the first thing you can do,
I look in the backseat cause that's
where it would've went. Not there.
And I look in the back,
not there and you know,
you get that cold feeling that just
rushes over your body. I go, oh my God.
So I'm like, man, so whatever I tell
you and you're like, whoa. You know,
get on the phone, you know,
call the airport and Bra.
You ever tried to call him the
airport or something? Yeah,
I told you this afterwards. My
opinion was at that point, divers,
that thing's gone.
100% gone,
gone 99.9999% you're never
going to see that thing again.
I had already cut it away emotionally
and detached from it and I was kind of
thrown you bones like yeah, call the
airport, maybe they can help you.
That was actually nice of you because
you really, you seem like you care.
Not necessarily about the
Karen necessarily, but you
cared about me. You know,
like early fan.
I thought that thing was gone.
There's no chance of getting it back,
get over it. And I was a little bit,
well I said,
you know,
is there podcast recorded that you don't
have copies of on there? And you said,
no, they're all uploaded.
I'll say, good thing. Awesome.
Cause we're never going to see that
thing again. And I was thinking,
I'll see it again in three months,
maybe when they finally
recover it from Austin,
found from the Boston airport by the way.
Or I get my insurance money for down
the line and then you got to go read,
go through the purchase process,
which is a thing,
but we don't have it
for this trip for sure.
And later on I found out or realized that
we have the podcasts like SD cards in
there. So while we, I guess we
could have just bought some anyway,
nonetheless we get there and I'm calling
the airport and right on the airport
recording picks up. Yeah. Just
get this feeling like, oh my gosh,
I'm just completely going
through the motions right now.
No one's going to pick up and be like,
sure, I'll look for it. Yeah, I got it.
And no one, that's not going to happen.
But I keep calling and I'm like,
I'm not going to be the guy
who didn't do everything I can.
So I'm calling or whatever. Meanwhile,
we got to go talk to Pete, we got to,
you know, all this stuff that
you released me. You go, hey man,
go ahead and make these calls. And I was
like, okay, cool. You hang out with that.
Just make us totally worthless effort
because you're never seeing that thing
again. I'll go hang out with people.
Yeah. So after like a few minutes of that,
I go in, I'm like, you know what, let me,
let me kind of cut it away and saying,
let me at least it embraced it.
You know what we're doing.
Go in and you kind of kind of
casually in a way mentioned like, hey,
there's some guys from the police. If
that came across casually, casually,
I shouldn't have made it come work
because I met a bunch of guys, you know,
everyone was just saying hi. And a couple
of guys are, you know, yeah, we're,
we're cops and [inaudible]
down in Massachusetts and
right by boss to go right
next to it.
And,
and I met them and then you stroll
back in and you met a couple people.
And then I said, you talked
to anybody. Well, yeah,
I talked to this and they're
going to look whatever.
I'm thinking you have things
gone. And I said, you know,
if there's anyone in the world that could
like make something happen right now
it's cops. Yeah. So
it's, it's Boston cops.
Ravinia cops and what? And,
and I just said, I said, bro.
And I was a little, this is my
ego. I was embarrassed for you.
I felt bad that you had to go and tell
somebody that you lost this. Yeah.
Sick camera. And so I just said, hey
man, those guys over there, they're cops.
And if there's anyone that gets going
to get this thing back, it's them. Yeah.
And I'm thinking, you know,
the whole story where like,
did you see this? So did you not think
that they were going to be able to help?
I thought that they'd be
like, Oh, you lost your bag.
Like everyone does every single day
at that airport. Oh, we're cops, bro.
We have crimes to solve.
Yeah, no, I get your stupid.
My attitude of that thing
being gone actually changed.
As soon as I connected it and said to
myself, oh they're cops, we're going to,
we're going to turn this over to them and
they can make things happen that, that,
that's good. And Youth and
even me when I was like, okay,
I'm going to mention it to these cops
and these cops are going to be like diva,
like what do you, what do you
think our job is? You know,
to go recover your lost luggage. He's
like w three hours away by the way. No.
So I'm like, you know what Jocko said
to do it, I'm just going to do it.
This is another go
through the motions thing.
So I kind of timidly go Dennis and Nate,
they were there,
they just rolled it, whatever. And
I was like, Hey, I lost the bet.
And they were like, what did it look
like? Like they kind of were into it.
I was like, oh this is promising,
you know, like they actually care.
Cause I was thinking they'd be like,
man, that's a sad story. Broke.
I'm going to go talk to Jocko
again, you know, kind of thing.
I thought that was going to
happen. And they were like, no bro.
They get on the phone and they're
like, what'd it look like? Boom.
One more question like, Oh, where are
you? Where'd you leave it? Okay, boom,
back on the phone, back on the
phone. These two guys, I'm like,
oh this is, it's starting to kind
of look up. And he's like, okay.
So they hang up the phone. He
was like, just a waiting game.
Now just a matter of time I got this,
I got this guy and I'm like thrilled.
They're like, yeah man, just the waiting
game. So we're talking called it.
They called all their bros is out there
and there was like a force of troopers
from my daughter to get in there. Had
that thing recovered in what, 20 minutes,
how many minutes? They hang up and
they're like, just amount of time bro.
And then we just start talking
about other stuff. Yeah. You know,
kind of teasing me a little bit, whatever.
I deserve it and I'll even 10 times up.
But, and then we were talking about other
stuff. Boom. His phone rings, he's on it.
He's like, is it of mine? Shift bit
bag and all this and describing it,
I don't even know. That's how I'd
have to, I'm like, yeah, I think so.
Go inside and needs any,
any bus up my laptop or whatever.
It's matching the description
and in my mind I'm like,
there's no way he found it.
Like a cop's not going to just roll
into the Logan Airport and find my bag.
No way that's going to happen. But it
happens. Sure enough, he's like, Oh,
you're a fragment cause it has a fragment
sticker on my laptop. And he's like,
frag mobile like that.
We'll pull the feeling turned into just
warmth and love and rainbows on this guy.
I was like, that's the one they're
like, and you know, they're kind of,
they didn't actually high
five, but they're kind of
like almost like, you know,
this was this little tasks.
They kind of bonded over that and
just like that morning minutes, man
who drove it up? Um, Robbie,
that's his name, right Ravi.
Yeah. I owe him a role. Um,
actually there was another guy,
Callahan who was the guy
who went and grabbed,
so he was like a coordinated
dealmaker and um,
man does like one of the more heroic
things that has happened to me and in the
recent past.
So you've got the camera back,
got the camera behind the computer
and we're good. So in the event,
so the point is in the event
of you shopping for cameras
can get a red camera on
Amazon,
but if you want to get like a Sony HD
handicap or whatever you're using because
it broke in the luggage.
I'm not saying that happened to me,
I'm just saying if that ever happened
to you and to get another one, boom,
you can go through their Jocko store.com
click through and thanks to everyone to
cut that camera back.
Yeah, much appreciated.
And the laptop with all kinds of
videos and important stuff on it. Yeah.
Actually those guys are on the laptop
but, but yeah, man Dennison, Nate,
the primary guys,
Mr. Callahan,
I didn't meet him but he's
done because he recovered that.
And then Robbie, I owe you a role. Oh
you two rules. I owe you a lot, man.
You the man, he's the one who delivered
it so big up to all of them. Big Time.
So also back to support of Jocko podcast,
subscribe to the podcast,
iTunes, stitcher, Google play.
It's a good way to support kind of kind
of kind of obvious like oh yeah you
subscribed already. But some
people, maybe they didn't.
Maybe they were just kind of maybe
wish not wishy washy but you know,
kind of still on the fence.
But man do it well at your,
you can unsubscribe if
we're not delivering value.
I don't like to use that
expression. Adding value.
Everyone uses thinks it's cool.
I thought
it was cool the, if we're not adding
value, you cannot subscribe if you want.
Also subscribe on Youtube.
What's the recent development?
Oh your book.
Dismissible field manual field manual,
which she'll talk about later.
We put a video on there.
It kind of little summary.
I was real excited to see
that video come out. Yeah.
And I was, we, you know,
we were texting back and forth and he
said, well, how about, you know, we will,
I'll put it out tomorrow, but it's ready.
And I said, just put it out now. Yeah,
yeah, yeah. Late. Then you
said launching in three,
two and then there was,
and I went to my youtube on my phone
and I was refreshing, refreshing,
refreshing, refreshing, refreshing.
And I wanted to catch it like the first
person to catch it. I'm refreshing,
refreshing.
And this happened,
I got a ping from my mail on my phone
and I switched to mail and it said Jocko
podcast is upload a new video.
So that's one of the benefits of
subscribing to the youtube channel.
If something comes out, you can
have it email you if you want it to,
if you can have it,
email you when something new comes out
and otherwise there's no way you'd know.
Yeah. So if you, if you care about
they 10 stuff, which you know,
it's one of those deals where, yeah, sure,
you get the video version of the podcast.
If you care what we look like,
you just fine. Actually, people
will play it on their TV,
like in their little home gym or
something like that, which was cool.
It's kind of like we're all there
together, you know? Um, and then, yeah,
some excerpts in there. The video
that you made for the book. Yeah.
I think it might be your best video ever.
It might be. I think it's up there man.
I was, yeah, I was
talking. It's real good.
I'll talk to somebody on face book and
they're like, oh hey, that video was cool.
And I thought about saying like, oh,
that was like, you man. Thanks for that.
But I thought about it. It's like, wait,
Jocko kind of did all the work. Really.
You know, you're the one working out your
word that you saying the words I said,
all I did was put some cool music
and some words on there. They'd,
all that other stuff happened in there.
The words and the way it's all
coordinated together and all that stuff.
So I have two lights on there nonetheless.
You know what, I'm to be honest. Um,
I like how it came out too. He was good.
He's theory, they're getting the best one.
Hey men. You know, it depends on what
you mean by best, you know, I dunno.
Impactful and then back. Well sure.
That's a good one. I liked it. Yeah.
It was, if someone wasn't subscribed to
the youtube channel, yeah. They might not,
never know that that video exists.
That's true. And that that's,
that hurts or no Facebook or
no Twitter or no, nothing.
Yeah. Yeah. So choose your, your, your
wealth that I tweeted that one out,
but I don't always tweet out
when something comes out.
Yeah, yeah, that's true. No.
Yeah, don't always do that.
Sure. So if you subscribe,
you'll know regardless of what my
actions are. That's true. And you know,
choose whether or not you want an alert.
You know,
sometimes you don't want that alert
every single time, but sometimes you do.
You know,
I'll put
some deleted scenes on there
as well. Anyway. Nonetheless.
Yeah. Youtube channel,
we have one and it's cool. I think
it's cool. Juggle things at school law.
I just got a little thing. Youtube
kind of changed their look on Youtube.
I don't know if you notice that.
It's hard for me to judge because
I have youtube red now. No ads,
so dope. Nonetheless, I liked the
ABS ads. Actually they did good.
A good thing with the ads now.
Now you can click like,
I don't like this ad or you can give
that so you can kind of narrow down the
ads. You See, I liked
the movie trailer ads.
You know like I don't like in the ads.
Yeah,
I did watch what I want to watch everyone
else get away from me. Yeah, yeah.
I dig it. I dig it fully. Oh
nonetheless, the point there is subside.
Subscribe to the Youtube Channel is a
good way of supporting the podcast if you
want to. Also Jocko was a
store. It's called Jocko store,
Jocko store.com. Of course.
Very creative name by the way.
I guess technically I came up with a name.
You did.
This store is your storage chocolate
store. I concurred with the name. Yeah,
so what do we have on the store?
If you don't know already,
we've got shirts on their
rash, guards, travel mugs,
some bumper stickers, patches, hats,
ball cap hats. Not like, did
you remind today top hats?
You don't look like you did.
Yeah. No I did. And Harris Servo.
You want me nine?
None the less they're on there.
Jocko.
xero.com.
I guess technically you could go to your
own story and get a hat or nine hats as
the case may be. I'll do that today.
Thank you. I appreciate it. If you want,
if you want to, um, so women's
stuff on there. Some hoodies,
we want to get a thicker hoodie.
That's what we're doing, right.
I know you said it a bunch
of times, but um, yeah,
we'll work on that. So
there, boom, hoodies. Uh,
I think
what,
what's the next move? What's
the next thing? Winter Hoodie.
Winter Hoodie. Yeah. Yeah.
I think it should be.
I think I'm going to put a warrior
kid rash guard on there too, for four.
Where he kids doing no Guid
Jujitsu or even, gee, you know,
you were the RushCard under the
east sometimes. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I think that'd be dope stuff nonetheless.
Jackals store,
that's where you get Jocko stuff.
It's pretty cool.
So I'm not saying to buy something.
I'm saying go on there, check it out.
If you like something,
get something good way to support all.
So psychological warfare,
if you didn't know what that is,
it is an album with tracks,
Jocko checks,
Jocko saying stuff to you. So if you
listen to it, it's not like a story,
right? Like, you know, a lot of
times it's not music, obviously.
It's not Jocko singing hardcore,
which you do from time to
time by the way he ever ride.
And here's a kind of a
rhetorical question. Kay, have
you ever written you Jocko,
but the people out there, have you
ever written with Jocko for five hour,
three to five hours in a car? No.
Okay. Let me tell you what it's like.
Part of what it's like, it's Jocko
drumming even in the airplane by the way.
Drumming on,
what do you call that?
The handle in the door and like you're
doing like drums bump and then singing
under his breath. Hardcore stuff.
Um, what else are you seeing?
What are you looking? Was like Tom
Petty or say it wasn't Tom Petty.
It was something anyway. I have no
idea. Yeah, but it was songs I was,
I noticed occasionally I'd look
at you and you'd be looking like,
can you please stop? Yeah, yeah. Which I
got a kick out of me. Yeah, you were born.
Yeah. Or, or stop the car and like get out
or something. Yeah. You get out and walk.
Yeah. Million drums. That was the
look for sure. Yeah. Wait, no,
you get out. Stop playing drums and get
out. That was the look. Nonetheless,
these tracks are not that they're him,
him [inaudible] talking to you,
telling you pragmatic ways
to get over your current
weakness. What? Weakness. Okay,
so let's say you're trying to
stick to a good diet, right?
Try to wake up early or all of the above.
Right at this moment.
Actually currently 48 hours
right now. Currently. Yeah.
Feeling good too.
I guess technically I'm fascinating
too because they ate a salad.
Oh hardcore workouts or yesterday
and today rolled last night,
70% ribs a little tweaked still.
But Andy Dean light roles
a little bit with Nam.
I think that was it. But yeah, no
listing the whole time. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yep.
So technically,
am I fascinating if I ate a
salad at like 1145 last night?
Well he knows it and drank
some coffee. Yeah. Fast, fast,
24 hour fast. No, no. Oh, 12
hour fast fasting. Got It.
Is there such thing as an eight hour fast?
I think that's just life.
I think it's like four and a half.
If you're not doing,
if you're not doing at least 12 hours,
12 hours is the cutoff for calling Nicole.
I don't know what to cut off the steering.
I'm not a doctor or even a nutrition goal.
You're fasting right now currently.
What if like you just didn't eat yet,
whatever, and I just didn't eat yet.
There's a difference. Yo. So what's
the difference? That's the question.
I don't know. Hey, you're,
you're a man of humility.
You say you didn't know and you
to know. I like that. Nonetheless.
Back to the psychological warfare.
If you're trying to stay on the
fast or wake up early every morning,
you know,
or stick to the Diet,
stay in the program,
whatever, in whatever way,
ways that you have opportunities to slip.
This is an album with tracks that tell
you why you shouldn't slip on your waking
up early, your diet, your working
out. My whole thing. You know,
like I've said before,
if I don't feel like working out,
I kind of tend to be like, oh, maybe
I'll rest today. Maybe I'll do it later.
You know, that whole thing,
not good. Yeah, this helps with
that.
It'll just tell you like why it'll,
how in a nutshell tells you the benefits
of not slipping and the repercussions
of slipping.
That's in a pragmatic way,
but does Jocko telling it to you so it
works 100% of the time. My experience,
speaking of fasting, people ask me
this all the time, when you're fasting,
do you eat anything? Yeah, I
do actually. Sunflower seeds,
sunflower seeds,
because it takes you like 37 minutes
to have one little tiny seed to get it
chewed up in a so, right. But they're,
but they're good because they keep you
occupied and you're chewing and they
taste good and blah,
blah blah.
Sometimes I'll grab a handful of nuts,
just mixed nuts.
Just maybe one in the morning,
maybe one at night,
one handful and Jocko white tea.
Boom.
That's the things.
Now sometimes I won't eat the nuts,
but I dunno, I I, I'm
you gotta be careful that you don't
have 13 handfuls of nuts. Yeah.
Cause I was like, I'm just talking
like a handful of nuts. Right. Um,
but Jocko white tea, I have that
for sure. And you know what,
if you call me now or
you want to put like, oh,
you weren't really fast and because
you have Jocko white tea and you have a
handful of nuts.
I mean,
if you think about the amount of
calories that I burned on a daily basis,
a handful of nuts as basically
and insignificant, but whatever.
Maybe I'm doing it wrong. That's okay.
I'm just telling you what I'm doing.
I'm not telling you to do it. I'm not
telling you to copy what I'm doing.
I'm just telling you what I'm
doing right now. Don't imitate me.
Go find a professional
to talk about fasting.
I'm just telling you what I'm doing.
Jocko white tea. Let me tell you,
it tastes good.
It feels good and increases your
deadlift about 12 fold or so.
Yeah, so that's real good for you. You
can get it on Amazon. Also on Amazon,
you can get some books, extreme
ownership, combat leadership.
I appreciate everyone that gets it for
themselves and then gets it for their
teams and sends pictures of 47
extreme ownership copies stacked up.
I got something else
for you that's awesome.
And get it for your business associates,
people that you work with,
but they're not in your company.
You get it for them and that's going to
improve everything in your world too,
because then they start taking ownership
of problems and everything gets better.
So I got, I've had a lot of
people that have said, hey,
I gave this to this person.
I gave this to this partner that I
used to have and now he's got his own
business,
but we're working together and I gave
him the book and now we're working
together even more. So there was a good
idea for you weigh the warrior kid.
This was awesome.
At the origin camp,
I'll bunch of people from all over the
northeast brought their kids up to to
meet, hang out, get a signature and all
that. And what's cool is what's cool.
Kids tell the truth, you know what I mean?
They don't even, they're not aware of,
they don't care about your feelings
at all. And it's awesome to, you know,
say I always say to Kiddo, did you
read that book? And they go, yes, I go,
how'd you like it? And they all
say, Oh, I love it. It's awesome.
And we know your Jocko and
thank you for writing it.
And those kids are getting stronger
and smarter and tougher and better.
Yeah. So you want to help out kids that
you know, get them this book right here,
discipline equals freedom field manual.
That's what it is. It's a field manual.
For those of you that don't know
what a field manuals in the military,
a field manual is. The instructions
on how to do something in the field,
whether it's attack a strong objective
or whether it's dual recognizance or how
to conduct a patrol.
The field manual gives you
the instructions on how
to do that and that's what
this is.
The discipline equals freedom.
Field manual is a field manual on how
to implement discipline into your life.
There's zero amount of fluff in here.
There's zero.
There's nothing in there that you'd say
you're going to say to yourself, well,
I think Jocko might've just
thrown this in here for, you know,
kind of take up some space in the
pages. Didn't happen. Rather not do it.
Rather burn the whole book. Don't care
about that. The book's not long enough.
Cool. Read less. So that's what it is.
Get it from your local bookstore.
So go down to the neighborhood bookstore
and tell him you want this book or you
can get it from Barnes Noble. You can get
it from Amazon. Let them know what's up.
It's in the get after it section of
your local bookstore. If they have one.
If they don't have that section,
they need it so they can put this one
book by itself in there getting after it.
Your video's awesome by the way.
Thanks John. For Your Business.
If you need help aligning your leadership
and improving the way that your whole
team leads together, check
out our leadership and
management consulting company.
It's called echelon front me, Leif, Babin,
JP to know Dave Burke.
You can email info@echelonfront.com
finally, the muster,
September 14th and 15th I'm pretty sure
it's sold out by the time this podcast
comes out. We've been able to squeeze a
couple more people in at each of these.
Even when we were sold out, we got
in like four, four more people,
three more people, seven more people
check. It might be completely sold out,
but extreme ownership.com
and it if you want to.
We're going to pretty soon get
the dates for 2018 musters going,
so started looking into that and get
registered as early as you can and until
the muster.
If you happen to want to keep
cruising with us kind of hard.
Uh,
we are on the Inter webs on Twitter,
on Instagram and a fee sheep or Aha.
Echo is at echocharles and IMF,
Jocko Willink.
And finally to the
military members out there
sitting on some forgotten barricade
holding the line to protect us.
Thank you to the vets that stood
on the wall and did their time.
Thank you
to the police, law
enforcement, firefighters,
EMT,
other first responders.
Thank you for what you
do day in and day out
and to the rest of you
with goals and dreams and aspiration.
Make sure you remember
that's seconds turned into minutes,
minutes turned into days
and days turn into years.
So make those seconds count
all of them.
They end up til next time.
This is echo and Jocko
out.